hello everyone welcome to the December
2023 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Caroll so I will confess that I thought
that maybe we would have some more
anyway questions this month that were
instigated by the recent spicy
controversial podcasts that we had you
know I did that solo episode on
artificial intelligence and indeed
online that got a lot of responses both
very very positive and very very
negative and it just reminds me that I'm
not built I'm not cut out for
controversy on the internet you know
which is weird to me because I love
academic controversy I love you know
talking to people who have thoughtful
opinions about things uh but as I
mentioned before it it is to those of
you who are not in Academia or not in
the good parts of Academia anyway there
is a difference with how disagreement
happens um you know academic
disagreements can get very heated very
personal very irrational sometimes but
for the most part when you give a talk
or you write a paper or whatever people
can entirely absolutely strongly
disagree and yet do so in a way that is
constructive you know that is offering
here are the reasons for my disagreement
Etc um that doesn't happen as much on
the internet and it just makes me sad to
get completely unhelpful kinds of
disagreement let's just put it that way
um but also I got some very constructive
comments so that was very useful not
that many questions about that stuff in
the AMA though likewise we had the even
more controversial episode with Derek
guy talking about fashion and the theory
and practice of it there it was just
much more um hilarious because people
reacted very negatively to it without
before they even could possibly listen
to it you know I know that when you
react to a podcast a minute after it has
been posted that probably you haven't
actually listened to it and again the
responses were remarkably not very
thoughtful for that one again we had
very good responses but there were a lot
of like oh you've lost your way what
kind of nonsense is this this is not why
I'm here cancel my subscription you know
that kind of thing which I've gotten
since the very beginning of doing mod
mindscape uh through the very beginning
of talking in public people have been
disappointed in me that I have not
talked about the things that they wanted
me to talk about and I'm going to keep
disappointing them but it's it doesn't
just roll off my back it does make me
sad that we get those kinds of responses
that's too bad I thought the episode was
great and I hope that the people who
listen to it actually learned something
about the theory behind uh this kind of
frivolous occupation that we call
dressing well what we did get this month
and as you'll see is a bunch of
questions about um the usual topics most
especially quantum mechanics which leads
me to mention that I have a new course
out through wum SL uh the Great Courses
wum and the Great Courses is the same
company the company that used to be
called the Teaching Company I basically
did a course on quantum mechanics based
on my book something deeply hidden so
we'll talk both about quantum mechanics
in general but also about the many
worlds interpretation in particular and
there were some things I did for the
Teaching Company course that I did not
do in the book there's a little bit on
Quantum Computing there's more on sort
of ethics and the the meaning of many
worlds things like that a little bit on
immersion SpaceTime and so forth so
that's 24 lectures half an hour each um
slickly produced by the people at the
teaching company and I think the only
difference I'm not even sure I
understand this but I think the
difference between the Teaching Company
label and the wum label is whether it's
streaming or whether you buy the DVDs so
go to either wum that's w n d r i u m or
uh the teach um the Great Courses have I
been saying the Teaching Company the
Great Courses and um you can get the
course I think probably I don't know
whether it's still True by the time
you'll hear this but there was at some
point a Black Friday sale anyway so much
knowledge for so little money that it's
worth it no matter what they are
charging for it it's a different
modality right like some people like
reading words on pieces of paper some
people like listening to audio some
people like watching videos Etc so if
you like watching the videos and seeing
the explanations with nice slick
animations and so forth this could be
the course for you likewise I wanted to
mention uh two other things bookkeeping
things one of course is that these ask
me anything episodes are sponsored by
supporters on patreon anyone can be a
supporter on patreon you can just go to
patreon.com shanm Carol and chip in a
dollar or whatever per episode of
mindscape you know it's much easier than
you think to just sign up for patreon
give a little dollar here and there not
just to me but to other creators and so
forth it's a nice thing to do you can
always get mindscape for free if you
listen to the ads but if you're on
patreon you get an adree version you get
to ask the uh AMA questions you also get
little reflection videos that I do after
each episode so a tremendous deal at
patreon.com shmc Caroll and the other
thing to mention is the mindscape big
picture scholarship which is still
ongoing which you can either donate to
if you're at that stage of your life or
apply for if you are a high school
senior which is at bold.org that's b.org
scholarships mindscape and I think that
we're already funded to give out one
scholarship this year and we're very
close to being able to give out two so
that would be awesome so if you we could
kick in uh we would go over the target
to be able to give out two scholarships
that's $10,000 to someone who wants to
go to college to study very difficult
big picture questions which is what
we're all about here and if you want to
apply for that scholarship please do the
application deadline is December 15 2023
and with that I think that's all the
bookkeeping we got to do so let's
go
our first question is from Rue Phillips
I loved the graphic your wife put out
recently showing the entertainment value
versus scientific value of time travel
movies movie making has always been
fascinating for me and I know you've
been involved in multiple Productions I
would love to hear from you about your
favorite and least favorite movie making
experiences and if you feel generous
about answering a followup I'm very
curious what you would do differently if
there was a new Pride and Prejudice
adaptation so what Ru is referring to is
that Jennifer and I did our first
written collaboration we do have a talk
that we gave together we sort of Tagg a
team to talk on black holes at the Royal
Institution in London that was a lot of
fun but we've actually never written
anything together we've certainly um
commented on and helped edit and shape
each other's individual writings but
we've never collaborated until now we
co-wrote a story for ours Technica which
is where Jennifer is a staff writer so
you can go to RS Technica look for time
travel and what we did was we took uh 20
time travel movies and we ranked them uh
not ranked but rated them let's put it
that way on a 0o to 10 scale on both how
successful they were as movies that's
one AIS of the plot the other plot the
other axis is how much sense they make
as time travel so that second axis means
both is this is the time travel more or
less scientifically respectable but also
does it make logical sense you know even
if you just disappear in a puff of smoke
and and reappear at a different time
which is not very scientifically
respectable you can still be internally
consistent right and and that's the kind
of logical points that we gave and
especially if you used time travel in a
very deep and important way you know
again we didn't go for controversy here
we were trying to celebrate the movies
that did it well 12 Monkeys does it
exceptionally well Interstellar got some
points but also lost some points for the
weirdness at the end and you know Star
Trek the Voyage Home does remarkably
well on these uh at least on the
scientific time travel kind of axis uh I
also thought it was actually quite a
good movie so you can read about those
rankings we had a lot of fun with that
and of course we get controversy you
know we don't look for the controversy
the controversy came in one part that we
expected and one part that we didn't one
part that we expected was that neither
one of us really liked the movie primer
and I know this is going to raise
people's hackles cuz it's a cult classic
and the people who love that movie
really really love it but we neither
loved it that much as a story nor as a
time travel logic thing the time travel
in primer is extremely
convoluted and there's a lot going on
which I think gives people the
impression that it's kind of deep but I
don't think it actually is very deep I
mean it does use time travel to um
that's very much the point of the movie
it's not just a little side device
obviously so it gets points for that but
at the end of the day it it does the
usual kind of time travel logic mistakes
about changing the past and not having
things be perfectly consistent Etc so
sorry primer fans we wanted to like it
really but it didn't quite work out
the weird thing that I wasn't expecting
is that in our list of 20 movies we did
not include Time Bandits and people got
very upset about that and I will I will
tell you right here right now we watched
Time Bandits for this purpose we thought
it was going to be on our list but the
thing is Time Bandits doesn't really use
time travel in any intimate way time
travel is in the movie that's true but
it's just an excuse to sort of be a
fantasy escaping to different parts of
the world by escaping to different
moments in time right it didn't actually
have any commentary on affecting the
past or going to the future or Loops or
anything like that there's not that
wasn't actually there in time bendit and
in fact by the end it's just obviously
over-the-top fantasy having nothing to
do with time travel at all so that's why
we didn't do Time Bandits sorry Time
Bandits fans look it's a list of things
on the internet what is the point of
list of things on the the internet if
not to disagree with them and put in
your own opinions in the comments you're
welcome to do that um as far as the
actual question that Ru is asking I
don't want to say you know what my least
favorite movie making experiences are
I've absolutely had experiences where I
did a certain amount of work you know
collaborated with a writer or director
whatever and it never came to anything
that's kind of frustrating sometimes but
that's very much the way that Hollywood
Works uh you know I think I mentioned
before back in my youth I had uh
Ambitions to maybe someday write a
screenplay or collaborate or something
like that but these days I would I don't
think I would be interested in doing
that anymore because it's just a weird
business model that Hollywood has where
you put a tremendous amount of work into
things then you get literally nothing to
show for it and I'm not even talking
about the recent Spate of Studios making
the whole movie and then just not
releasing them for some weird tax
write-off purposes I'm just you know
talking about the very very common thing
where as a writer in Hollywood you put a
lot of work into a screenplay you're
paid to do it even and then nothing ever
comes of it very very frustrating um in
terms of favorite examples actually I
think my
favorite uh experience there was on the
TV show Bones and again I've talked
about this before but it was a long time
ago um there was a wonderful episode
written where Richard Schiff who played
Toby on The West Wing played a physicist
on Bones and his daughter got murdered
and I'm not going to give away any
spoilers or anything like that but he
was a suspect and part of the reason why
he was a suspect is because they
portrayed him as a slightly
stereotypical physicist without a lot of
social skills so he didn't act as upset
about his daughter getting killed as the
investigators thought he should have but
then he finally managed to capture his
love for his daughter in a series of
equations almost like a little poem in
the form of equations and so I got to
write the equations and I got to write
the blackboards and I got to write other
some other lines of dialogue when uh the
character was talking about physics and
so forth so the characters Richard
schiff's characters most recent paper
bore a tremendously close resemblance to
a paper that I had recently written
let's just put it that way so that was
fun I actually got to be on set while
they were filming it and everything much
more involvement in TV than at the at
the movie level like movies are are you
know huge Industrial
efforts these days right so I've never
been on a movie set um and the writers
on a movie have much less effect on what
you actually finally see as the product
than they do in TV TV is a writer's
medium movies are more a director's
medium if not a Studio's medium so
writers for TV are the ones who are
important which is just not true in the
movie world as far as Pride imp pudus is
concerned my advice would be do not
adapt Pride PR and Prejudice it's
already been done more or less perfectly
by the BBC with Jennifer L and Colin fth
you don't need to adapt Pride and
Prejudice ever
again next two questions I'm going to
group two together one is by T Jansen
who says in the past you mentioned or
maybe in some way even recommended David
Wallace's book the emergent Multiverse
for a deeper dive into ever and quantum
mechanics but I get stuck especially the
parts beginning with as you recall from
your quantum mechanics textbooks these
are hard to understand for me cuz I
never had one there's a huge apparent
required knowledge gap between your
quantum mechanics books and this one can
you recommend a way to bridge that Gap I
don't mind to do some work for it but I
don't feel motivated to do unguided
self-study with a Copenhagen quantum
mechanics textbook and then Chris Murray
says the first biggest ideas book
features an essentially complete
description of what general relativity
is which though unaccompanied by many of
the tools needed to actually work with
it is tremendously insightful will the
second book provide similarly complete
descriptions of quantum mechanics or
Quantum field Theory or would that be
too much so I'm grouping these two
questions together because they both
involve the book that I just finished
copy editing which is uh Quant and
Fields that's going to be book two of
the biggest ideas in the universe Series
going to come out in May
2024 and it is just like book one the
idea is to be popular science to explain
things to everyone who's interested not
just to professional physicists but to
show you all the equations and it's
interesting because for Tia's question
um I don't know whether that will be a
good background but probably it's the
best thing I can think of you know some
linear combination of that book and the
susin series Lenny susin series on the
theoretical minimum he has a book on
quantum mechanics his book on quantum
mechanics is more sort of traditional
right straightforward here is how we
would do quantum mechanics if you were
learning quantum mechanics as an
undergraduate but without necessarily
quite as much detail as if you were
officially a physics student so a little
bit easier to get through um whereas my
book because it tries so so Lenny has a
whole book on quantum mechanics my one
little book is doing both quantum
mechanics and Quantum field Theory so
the all of quantum mechanics happens in
just the first three chapters and you
know there's 12 chapters total so most
of it is quantum field Theory which
leads me to Chris's question which
is is the level of detail is the level
of
completeness the same in the quantum
field Theory book as it is in the
general relativity book well no is the
short is the short answer and I say this
right at the beginning you know try to
be very upfront about it um when you do
relativity and classical mechanics you
can even in a relatively short book
basically give all of the equations in
in complete detail you won't like I said
like Chris said correctly um the goal is
not to try to solve the equations so
that's okay but you should at least
understand exactly what's in all the
equations in Quantum field Theory
Quantum field theory is just a much
larger subject than general relativity
is general relativity despite its
intimidating reputation is relatively
self-contained and the number of ideas
is relatively small whereas Quantum
field theory is enormous I mean just the
idea of a Quantum
field is more or less the same amount of
content as the idea of general
relativity but then you have to get in
the different types of fields you have
spinner fields and gauge fields and
scalar Fields you have to get into
renormalization and effective field
Theory you have to get into symmetries
gauge symmetries and group Theory you
have to get into the different phases of
quantum field Theory so you have higs
phase and kulum phase and confined phase
and you have to do all of that stuff not
to mention explaining what fan diagrams
are and interactions are and so forth so
there's a lot you have to do there are a
lot of equations honestly the density of
equations is maybe a little bit higher
in book two than in book one and the
equations are correct ones okay um but
not every detail is there in the same
way that it is in the relativity book
just as one example when you do Fons in
Quantum field Theory so a firon is spin
one half particles particles that take
up space and obey the P Exclusion
Principle like electrons and quarks and
neutrinos and so forth if you were a
student learning Quantum field Theory
there's a lot of effort that goes
into understanding the mathematical
structure of the fields representing
fermion so they are called spinner
Fields they have certain indices they
behave a certain way under Lorent
Transformations uh they involve things
like Po spin matrices and dur matrices
uh they anti-c commute with each other
at the mathematical level none of that
stuff is going to appear in the book but
things like the mass term and the
kinetic term and the interaction term
for firion with Gauge fields and also
things like the spin statistics
connection and why particles with spin
one/ half are firion and take up space
all of those conceptual things are there
so the difference in book two is I
really tried to focus on the
concepts to the extent that sometimes
the best way to focus in on the concepts
was to make the equations a little bit
simpler in this book than they would be
in an actual textbook so for for those
of you who are experts out there things
like fierz identities are not going to
appear in this book but hopefully I
really think that you know it the
there's still enough notation in there
that it will look weird and intimidating
if if you're not used to it so I
encourage people to give it a try and if
you do give it a try you will actually
come away knowing what is actually meant
by things like gauge symmetry uh
renormalization the higs mechanism
things like that so it's a fine line
that I'm trying to balance there in that
book we'll have to see whether it's
successful or not Robert Ren rescue says
for two or even 3 years my sister didn't
want to stop
eating and she didn't like walking or
doing any physical work not even for her
health she just ate and stood in bed
speaking to people on the phone because
of this she got heavier and heavier and
her oxygen levels started to go down
dramatically until we found her dead in
her bed a few weeks ago I could probably
have saved her if I and my family would
have put tremendous amount of effort
into this also she would have survived
if violence would have been used she
said that for a handful of times she
just didn't care if she lives and she
just wants to eat
my question is this how do you navigate
these complex issues how do you
determine if you should use violence to
save someone for example or if violence
is simply
unacceptable so I'm really really sorry
to hear about this Robert I mean Robert
has been a long time supporter of
mindscape and and asks a lot of great
questions in the amas over the years
this sounds like a really really
difficult thing to go through for
everyone involved so I'm sorry to hear
about it and I hope that you're doing
okay um and the issues are complex
there's no simple answers here in my
mind um and it depends on a lot of
things that I don't know so at some
level you have to navigate these things
as a human being rather than you know
hoping to find some clear crisp
algorithmic answers uh I think what it
comes down to is autonomy and
responsibility right I'm a big believer
that different people at least as long
as they are responsible and in their
right Minds should have the autonomy to
do with their lives and their bodies and
their brains what they want to do uh for
example in a slightly different example
but a related one it often is the case
that when people get older when they get
very old they want to do things that are
maybe considered unacceptably risky by
their children or their caretakers or
whatever and generally my perspective is
that they should be allowed to do that
it's their lives and they should be
allowed to do it
the question uh the reason why that
becomes complicated is because sometimes
it's not just risky but genuinely
self-destructive these kinds of
behaviors and then it is perfectly
reasonable to ask is the person engaging
in these
self-destructive behaviors are they
actually of sound mind as well as body
or are they struggling with some mental
illness or something that could be cured
by either medication or therapy or
something like that and I don't know and
I I'm sure that it's hard for anyone to
know the question like that uh at a
philosophical level the question is who
is responsible you know when is a
person when do they deserve to have the
right to make choices about themselves
you know someone who is an an addict for
example a drug addict or someone who you
know clearly has a kind of specific
mental illness that leads them to be
incapable of making decisions then I can
see other people intervening in some way
I don't you know I'm not quite sure why
the word violence is necessarily here
but certainly intervening in someone's
life to save their lives even if it's
against their will is absolutely allowed
under certain circumstances but other
under other circumstances I I think that
people have the right to decide and even
if that that decision is to let
themselves go or even end their lives I
think that that should be something that
people have the right to do uh but again
there's just no easy answers here the
only thing I would say is don't be too
hard on yourself for whatever might have
happened it's not like you made a
mistake it's not like there was some
clearly right thing to do and you didn't
have the guts to do it the the point is
that someone else your sister um was
making choices and the default should be
to let people make their the choices
even if they're not the choices you want
them to make I can imagine circumstan es
under which it is useful and necessary
to step in and intervene but those are
the exceptions rather than the rules so
don't be too hard on yourself you know
things happen sometimes terrible things
happen sometimes tragic things happen
sometimes preventable tragedies happen
even if everyone is doing the right
thing at every point along the way so um
sorry to hear that that had to happen uh
I hope that I hope that you sort of can
sort through it and and move on
again I don't think that you personally
seems like did anything wrong
whatsoever Sid Huff says you have noted
that democracy in the United States is
under threat if worse came to worse and
American democracy collapsed would you
and Jennifer consider moving to another
country assuming appropriate
professional opportunities presented
themselves I do think that American
democracy is under serious threat I
think that we are not as a culture as a
as a nation we're not taking that threat
nearly seriously enough you know I go on
about it uh I guess that's something to
do it's not very effective but it's a
little bit and um but so would we leave
the country that certainly wouldn't be
my first choice I could imagine doing it
um under certain circumstances but what
I would rather do is stay and try to fix
things try to fight try to make things
better you know I'm in a position where
uh it's easier for me it would be hard
for us to pick up and move for various
reasons friends house job all the usual
things we're very very established at a
certain part of our Lives you know we're
not just picking up and moving kind of
people right now but we have the
resources to imagine doing it whereas
other people don't even have those
resources and it seems not quite fair to
me to abandon those people when times
get tough so I don't know what it would
mean to resist and to keep fighting
against it Etc but that that would be my
first desire that would be my first
inclination is to try to make things
better you know democracies do come and
go and if they go they could possibly be
brought back again I don't know how to
do that but I would think that I would
like to think that I would
try Nick C says there is a recent
article in the Washington Post talking
about how John clauser who recently won
the Nobel Prize for quantum mechanics
experiments is a vocal climate denier
news which disappointed me quite a bit
from what I can tell his objections are
not terribly credible I guess I'm
curious for any thoughts you have on
that particular situation or the general
situation where professional physicists
go on to become crackpots in other
fields at what seems to me to be an
above average rate compared to other
scientists why does that happen well I
don't know why it happens you know this
is compatible with the perspective that
I have previously suggested that you
shouldn't have Heroes because people can
be really good at certain things and
really bad at other things and and I
don't know whether physicists go on to
become crackpots at a higher rate than
average um but some of them do become
crackpots that's absolutely true it
shouldn't be completely surprising let's
put it that way and the reason why it
shouldn't be completely surprising is uh
it would be a mistake to think there is
something called general purpose
smartness there just isn't there are
different kinds of smartness and Common
Sense is one of them an ability to judge
different sources of evidence is another
an ability to do very very precise
accurate physics experiments is a very
different one than either one of those
so physics is perhaps you know the most
hypers specialized of the Sciences it's
it's the most advanced science and I
don't mean that as as bragging it's it's
the easiest science as i' as I've often
said the questions that physics asks are
very deep and very profound but they're
also easier to address and make progress
ress on than questions in biology or
psychology or or things like that so as
a result you can be a super successful
physicist with a rather narrow skill set
with being really really good at one
very particular thing you can be a Nobel
prizewinning physicist there's zero
reason to think that that particular
skill set should generalize to other
hard problems and as a result you see
plenty of people who are high highly
credentialed physicists whose opinion
about issues that are not within physics
are completely
Bonkers and climate change is one of
them climate change is absolutely one
where the number of physicists who are
very successful have found it more
attractive to be Saucy contrarians than
to actually just get the right answer
which is pretty darn clear at this point
so I don't know exactly whether
physicists are more likely to do that
than others but I do think that makes
sense that you can be a super successful
physicist and also Bonkers on other
things there are physicists who are
believers in parasyche or whatever you
know physicists are should be well let's
put it this way I once um had I was
talking when I was a postto about some
philosophy question with one of my
physics professors and we were in my
office and there was a I think it was
like the fan lectures on physics was on
my desk and the professor was arguing me
about about this philosophy question and
said like you know what would Richard
feinan say about philosophy and I said
look I will take very very seriously
whatever Richard feinan has to say about
physics about theoretical physics
Quantum field Theory quantum mechanics
in particular I see Zero reason to take
seriously what Richard feeman has to say
about anything else at all I'm sure that
sometimes he's right I'm sure that
sometimes he's wrong just like any other
human being but the ability to be really
really really good at Quantum field
Theory does not give you any special
expertise in anything else now I
absolutely realize I'm opening myself up
to being criticized because I talk about
all sorts of things right and what I
would say is yes I do talk about all
sorts of things just like Richard feinan
did and Richard feineman has every right
as does John clauser to talk about
whatever they want so do I but you
shouldn't believe what I have to say
about climate change or politics or
religion
or what John Clouser says or Richard
fean says just because we're physicists
if you believe or don't believe do so
because what we're saying makes sense
and comports with the data and your
understanding of the arguments and
things like that I'm going to keep
talking about all sorts of things but
you should think about it not just
believe what I say because I'm a
physicist not that anyone ever has but
just to point out I am not asking you to
do
that John capston asks a priority
question remember that if you are an uh
patreon supporter then you get to ask a
priority question once per lifetime I'm
going to just trust that no one abuses
the privilege and tries to sneak in with
different names or anything like that uh
and with the priority questions I will
do my best to answer them so John asks
imagine that a spin up particle is spit
into spin left and spin right components
the components interact with two quantum
computers whose operation is then
reversed so that when when the spin
components are brought together again we
recover the original spin up state is it
true that the quantum computers cannot
be acting as conscious observers
measuring their respective spin
components because if they did then we
would have ended up with a spin left and
spin right particle rather than a spin
up
particle so this is a somewhat not I'm
not completely clear on the experimental
setup here so let me say things that I
think are true if you take a spin up
particle as John says you can measure
its spin so it's spin up along the
z-axis let's say but you measure its
spin along the x-axis you measure it in
some axis that is perpendicular to how
it is originally oriented so you will
get it 50/50 split between Spin left and
spin right and you can do that and you
have to be careful you don't want to
measure it but you can split it okay so
you can send it through a magnetic field
and then you have a component that is
going spin left a component that's going
spin right but you don't actually
measure either one of them you just know
that that's what they're doing because
you understand the rules of quantum
mechanics and then you send these spins
into a quantum computer and you process
them now ordinarily that processing
would involve at some point doing a
measurement and then when you do that
measurement the spin that you had will
disappear in one of the two apparatuses
that you just sented through you'll be
in one branch of the wave function the
spin only would have gone into one
quantum computer and not into the other
in the other Branch it would have gone
into the other and not the first one you
can invent something that you're going
to choose to call a quantum computer for
which no measurement or decoherence or
branching happens so basically that's
just a fancy way of saying I have my
wave function that is has these two
different parts to it the spin left part
and spin right part I'm going to let
those things interact but not become
entangled with anything that they're
dealing with
it is only if they never become
entangled that I could ever bring them
back together to get a spin up particle
okay so if they didn't become entangled
with anything then it it's almost as if
quantum mechanics is not relevant to
what is happening right it has nothing
to do with conscious
observers the it is true that the the
correct thing to say is that these two
things that you're choosing to call
quantum computers even though they're
not really regular quantum computers cuz
regular quantum computers do involve
measurements these two things you're
choosing to call as quantum computers
did not measure their respective spin
components so has nothing to do with
Consciousness they just didn't measure
them they didn't measure them as
conscious observers they didn't meure
measure them as unconscious observers
now there's a more subtle question do
you have to do measurements to be a
conscious Observer well no one quite
agrees on the definition of what a
conscious Observer is I would argue that
to be a conscious Observer you have to
participate in the arrow of time so you
have to generate entropy in the universe
to form memories and things like that
and therefore um in general things that
you recognize as conscious observers
will be doing measurements uh increasing
the entropy of the universe Etc
something that is completely pristine
and reversible would not in general in
my mind count as a conscious
Observer Scher says in your Reflections
following the wieners Smith's podcast
you app that living is good life is good
having more life elsewhere in the
universe would be a good thing do you
think of this as a Bas level subjective
preference or does it reflect some
underlying principle such as valuing
complexity or Joy well I'll I'll confess
I do not think that this is any deep
philosophical statement or it's
certainly not an overarching absolute
principle it's just a vague feeling I
think that I personally prefer a
universe with living creatures in it I'm
not going to say that we need to
maximize the number of creatures or
anything like that but I like living
this is this is absolutely my subjective
preference um there are people out there
who wish there were no living creatures
in the universe I don't get it I know
that living creatures do both good
things and bad things but overall I
would like there to be living creatures
yeah that is a hill that I will I will
try to defend Roland Weber says in
chapter six SpaceTime of the biggest
idea in the universe volume one you
write here's an idea let's define the
energy of an object in relativity to
just be that zeroth component of the
four momentum that felt like it was just
dropping out of the sky why can we
ignore the three spatial dimensions of
the four momentum and just pick the time
Dimension here well we're not ignoring
the the three spatial dimensions of the
four momentum those three spatial
Dimensions have a name already they are
called the momentum you know if you are
doing pre- relativity physics if you're
doing Newtonian mechanics Newton
wouldn't have said this because he
didn't know about these ideas but if
you're doing Newtonian mechanics before
Einstein came along you would have said
there is a three-dimensional Vector
called momentum and there is a scalar
quantity a Zero Dimensional number
called Energy so you have four numbers
the one number of energy and the three
numbers of momentum all that happens in
relativity is that those four numbers
get combined together to make a four
vector
and the way that they get combined
together is that the energy is the
zeroth component the Tim likee component
of the four momentum and the ordinary
three-dimensional momentum are the
spatial components of the three momentum
it's not just a definition it's not a
definition in any sense well in some
sense it's a definition because of
course when you go to relativity the
actual formulas for energy momentum get
changed a little bit they get changed in
a way that you wouldn't notice if you
were moving slowly compared to the speed
of light but once you start moving near
the speed of light you begin to notice a
lot but they all reduce to the usual
quantities when you have slow velocities
with of course the tiny exception that
there is an intrinsic energy to any
object that is just sitting there namely
MC squared the rest energy of an object
is MC squ but that doesn't really matter
in pre- relativity physics because it's
just a constant it doesn't really change
with time or anything like that in
relativity then you can change you can
turn that energy into other forms of
energy so that's why it turns out to be
a sensible definition to make even
though the it's it's a definition that
is just a generalization to relativistic
contexts of the definitions that you
already had EMT Francis asks do all
nonrotating black holes have a spherical
Event Horizon uh short answer is yes of
course there's always a longer answer
one part of the longer answer is what do
you mean by the word spherical uh in
mathematics we distinguish between
topological spheres which are just sort
of a sphere but you can deform it
smoothly into any shape you want so an
oblate spheroid would still
topologically be a sphere versus
geometrically a sphere which I I swear
to God this is true the technical term
is the round sphere so a nonrotating
black hole in three non-compact spatial
Dimensions plus of course the onetime
dimension will have a perfectly round
spherical Event Horizon if you let the
black hole and that's true whether it's
charged or not charged if you let the
black hole spin then it becomes an
oblate sphere so the aventon is still
topologically a sphere but geometrically
it's not round by the way I'm assuming
that we're talking about the event
horizon at One Moment In Time at uh the
full Event Horizon is a surface in
SpaceTime that is a null surface uh it
extends in time as well as space and
light rays are exactly parallel to it in
the right direction but anyway I think
that probably what you're getting at is
at any one moment of time in three plus
one Dimensions with all the dimensions
large then a non-rotating black hole
will indeed have a spherical eventor
eyes and this is part of the no hair
theorem for black holes basically any
black hole is completely once it settles
down and after it's made it be
completely characterized by mass charge
and spin so if it's not spinning it's
just characterized by mass and charge
and the full metric is the short Shield
metric for uncharged black holes the RIS
or norer metric for charged black holes
they both have spherical event Horizons
I keep saying 3+1 Dimensions because
there are weird things called black
strings if you have a compact extra
dimension of space then you can have a
black hole whose Event Horizon is kind
of like a cylinder in that extra
Dimension but those are subject to
various instabilities and it's a subtle
question so the rough answer to this
question is yes they are
spherical yasus says according to my
Layman understanding about Quantum field
Theory the mass of a single particle is
resulted by an interaction between an
exitation of the higs field and an
exitation of the electron field it seems
to me that higs field should have
positive and negative excitations if
that's correct theoretically can there
be a particle with negative mass as a
result of the interaction between a
negative exitation of the higs field so
nope there cannot be a particle with a
negative Mass but more importantly there
there's a couple of misconceptions going
on here the uh Mass so for one thing
super duper important and I talk about
this a lot in the upcoming book because
people get the wrong impression in
Quantum field Theory there's no rule
that says you need a higs bon particle
or a higs field in empty space in order
to get Mass if you think about the
history of quantum field Theory the
first really successful one was dur and
Quantum electrodynamics which later was
even more successful after fan and
schwinger and tomonaga Etc showed how to
renormalize it but there you have a
theory that doesn't have any higs bosons
in it it's from the 1930s and it has
electrons and positrons and they both
have mass there's no problem at all
what's up with that the issue is that in
the specific context of the standard
model of particle physics and in
particular in the specific context of
the weak interactions as they are
understood in the Weinberg Salam Electro
week unified theory there there's a very
special property which is that
left-handed particles and right-handed
particles are treated
differently this is parity violation
which was unknown in the 1930s and it
turns out that when you have parity
violation of this form then you cannot
have mass for the Fons without a higs
mechanism a higs boson in empty space so
Weinberg figured out how to fix that
problem by adding the higs boson in but
that's only because of the specifics of
the standard model and in particular the
parody violation so it's not true that
just to get Mass you need a higs to get
mass in this particular Theory where
left and right-handed particles have
different symmetries then you need the
higs particle to get a mass and the next
thing is it's not exit ations in the
higs field that give Mass to other
particles it's the expectation value not
excitation so an excitation is the
vibrations over and above what we call
the expectation value the expectation
value is just the average value of the
field in empty space so that's a
positive number it is unambiguously
positive for the higs boson a
fluctuation of the exitation the
expectation value would make it a little
bit less positive or a little more
positive but still positive and it's
that expectation value that matters an
exitation of the higs field gives rise
to higs BOS on particles which Play No
role at all in getting masses for
electrons and things like that it's only
the average background expectation value
that
matters Sandro stooky says science has
it its experiments mathematics has its
proofs but how do philosophers settle an
argument or do they can you tell us a
bit about the process by which
philosophical communities you are part
of make progress on important questions
sure they have arguments and logic and
reason I mean the usual way that people
settle arguments of course philosophy is
a very very broad field there are parts
of philosophy that are very formal
mathematical logic is part of philosophy
and there you literally have a proof
okay with the rules of logic expressed
in certain ways there are questions in
you know let's take something that we're
all very familiar with here um the
collapse of the wave function in quantum
mechanics okay and it is philosophers
who really have insisted that this is
not okay the sort of traditional physics
Copenhagen version of the collapse of
the wave function because it makes no
sense because it's incomplete because
it's just not well defined maybe
something like it is true but it's not
well specified so a philosopher will say
look here is where in your description
of what happens in quantum mechanics you
have been unclear here is where you need
to be more precise you need to Define
what these words mean it's an argument
using reason and rationality right and
of course they might suggest a solution
to that the philosophers of physics are
less good at solving these problems than
pointing out when they exist in
questions like morals and ethics or um
epistemology or metaphysics different
kinds of fields will have different
standards for what constitutes an
argument but very very often you will
see something like a formal syllogistic
argument uh arguments by induction or by
basian reasoning or something like that
as well as good old deductions P if P
then Q therefore Q kinds of things um
very often you know these arguments are
informal which is also true in math by
the way we all know uh well sorry
mathematicians have established what it
would mean to give a incredibly careful
precise rigorous mathematical proof of
something and they never do it to be
really actually precise is just
incredibly unwieldy and mathematicians
all know this so even though the
standards for rigor in a real math paper
are much higher than in physics papers
or whatever they're still not anywhere
close to the quintessence of
formalization that for example Russell
and Whitehead did in Russell and
Whitehead did in their book uh prinkipia
mathematical where they tried to
establish the foundations of arithmetic
and they didn't quite succeed perfectly
but okay that that's a different
question so yeah just the usual way that
we make progress on other kinds of
arguments you know what are your
assumptions what are your conclusions
did you derive them
carefully Jesse rimler says in a recent
AMA you said that the economic system
you prefer is regulated capitalism you
noted that a free market leads to more
efficient pricing and Innovation as
opposed to the planned economies found
in socialist system
the defining feature of capitalism one
could argue is not the free market but
private ownership of capital capitalist
owners decide what to do with profits
employees rent themselves out for a wage
and have little to no say about how a
company operates in this way the
capitalist model is fundamentally
undemocratic of course socialist systems
have been state-run undemocratic or even
totalitarian but another model in the
Socialist tradition is the worker-owned
Cooperative this setup extends democracy
to the workplace giving workers the
ability to determine how profits are
distributed and how to grow or innovate
their companies I'm curious about your
reactions to these definitions and
models you know as far as definitions
are concerned you can Define things
however you want um it doesn't really
matter to me and also I I I guess I it
rubs me a little bit the wrong way to
say that capitalism is not Democratic
because there is private ownership of
capital it's Democratic in the sense
that there is private ownership of
capital but anyone can be a capitalist
right any person could privately own
Capital there's no intrinsic
discrimination in that kind of system of
course there's de facto discrimination
because people are not born into
equivalent circumstances in the world
and that is absolutely an issue that you
could take that is a fact that you could
take issue with that you could disagree
with but the idea that anyone can be a
capitalist is what makes it Democratic
also I don't care if it's Democratic or
not I think that government should be
democratic atic for an economy I want it
to serve the purpose of the economy I
want everyone to be well off to the
extent that that is possible so but
that's just all definitional issues I
think that you're raising a very
interesting good question about private
ownership of capital versus Collective
ownership of capital you know I'm open
to the possibility that this is a a good
idea I'm a little bit skeptical because
I'm not sure that this is stable in some
sense you know this is always one of the
big problems with socialist attempts to
reformulate how the economy works is
that they tend to be a little utopian
they tend to say well if you have this
kind of setup then everybody will be
happier but the problem is they propose
a setup and again I'm not saying this is
true I'm saying this is the thing to
worry about that I would have to see
established they propose a kind of setup
that is unstable to people taking over
right it's unstable to inequality you
have an some kind of equality built into
system but the usual workings of the
system drive it toward inequality in
some way I don't think it's you know I
don't think it's fair to
criticize Socialism or communism just by
pointing to the USSR or the Communist
Party of China or other realworld 20th
century implementations of things that
called themselves communist because I
don't think that they were very uh true
to the ideals that KL Marx would have
noticed but I am completely sympathetic
to the critique that that kind of um
lack of fidelity to the original goals
is more or less inherent in the system
that could just be a very natural kind
of thing that any attempt to be a
traditional communist Society will end
up in these kinds of anti-democratic um
unequal distributions of power and
wealth I again I don't know that for
sure but that's what I would worry about
and again I think that what matters to
me much more is what the effects are you
know when it comes to economies I am
pretty consequentialist when it comes to
governments I am less consequentialist I
think that my most important reasons for
supporting de democracy are more
deontological I think that people have
the right to have a voice in the way
their government is run um I'm less sure
that people have a right to own the
company that they work for again you
could make the argument but that's less
obvious to me and I think that I'll just
say it again I said it many times what
we should do is we should tax the beesus
out of people we should let people um
individuals are motivated they're more
motivated for their self-interest than
for the greater good on average not
always but on average and I think that
an economy that is driven by that
self-interest can be very very effective
and then we let people earn a lot of
money and we take a lot lot of it back
to redistribute it by the government
that seems like a relatively good system
that's certainly not exactly what we're
doing right now we're letting people
keep a lot of the money far more than
any individual um really really needs
even to be quite
successful TJ mcmarro says what is your
view on the I think relatively Fringe
fields of econophysics sociophysics and
other projects which attempt to apply
physics Andor physical principles more
or less directly to domains well outside
its standard purview well I love these
fields I love it when they are done well
I am completely sympathetic to the idea
that often they are not done well you
know physicists have a completely earned
reputation for thinking that they can
Waltz into other fields and clean up all
their problems with just a few minutes
of work and being spectacularly wrong
about that feeling like I said before
there's nothing about being a successful
physicist that gives you any special
insight into other fields of endeavor
however I do think that there are fields
that there are not Fields but ideas
Concepts that physicists do develop in
the very very simplified contexts that
they care about in the spherical cow
contexts that can very well be a wider
applicability uh whether it's ideas of
um entropy and friction and momentum or
ideas of networks and interactions and
energy
or ideas of phase Transitions and
Collective behavior and emergence there
are a lot of ideas that come from
physics uh that could in principle be
very applicable to other areas otherwise
I would not be working on a book called
the physics of democracy which is
exactly what I am working on I think
that it is it is absolutely the
responsibility of anyone who wants to
think in these terms to be very very
careful that the usual
simplifications and assumptions the
physicists like to make still hold in
the context where they are considering
things they often don't which is why you
have to be more careful when you talk
about economy or Society or things like
that in terms that physicists would
recognize shahil Abdullah says what is
your opinion about cryonics do you see
any legitimacy or future in it well I
don't think that there is any violation
of the laws of physics involved in the
idea that we could freeze somebody
cryonically and wake them up later on
there are enormous challenges at a
practical level and I think that we are
nowhere close to
actually addressing these challenges so
I think that current ideas current
literal attempts to cryonically freeze
people in the hope of waking them up
sometime in the future are complete
quackery complete scams honestly but
maybe in the future it could happen you
know biology is something that
lots of progress remains to be made
we're nowhere close to figuring it all
out how to do things so I can easily see
lots of progress along these lines in
the future I have no idea how fast it
would happen Andrew Goldstein says do
you have any noteworthy discussions you
can share about the classes you've been
teaching in the physics of democracy or
the philosophy of physics well I mean
yes and no uh I've had lots of
noteworthy discussions I don't like to
discuss the discussions that we have in
class class outside of class the know
the classes for those of you who are
just tuning in this year and last year
uh at John's Hopkins I've been teaching
small seminars for undergraduates last
year I taught um a seminar on the
physics of democracy another seminar on
the philosophy of physics this year I'm
teaching a seminar on philosophical
naturalism and another one on the Arrow
of time so these are not lecture courses
these are courses where I might get up
and talk about something but mostly
we're sitting around the table
discussing things and it's a different
kind of thing if I stand up and give a
lecture then I'm generally completely
okay with having that lecture recorded
or talked about or whatever that's fine
that's me and I'm supposed to be
prepared but an a seminar is where
you're supposed to be responding in the
moment right without necessarily having
thought about things uh ahead of time
you're supposed to be working through
ideas so generally I don't think that
those things should be recorded either
formally or even talked about after
afterward so not trying to avoid your
question uh Andrew but I do think that
um I don't want to say anything too
specific I will say it's been a lot of
fun you know I think that um this kind
of course is just the quintessence of a
university education to me the idea is
you know sitting around a small number
of people really grappling with
something at a deep careful level and
talking with each other about it is just
wonderful it also doesn't work for
everything um certainly it's it's much
more intrinsically successful on the
philosophy side than on the physics side
on the physics side we've had very good
discussions you know that movie the
article that Jennifer and I wrote about
time travel in movies was inspired
directly from the course that I'm
teaching on the Arrow of time because
for the course we had some movie Nights
where we watched a couple of time travel
movies and we discussed them and that
was great fun and that got us thinking
about the whole thing but in physics
there's going to be more material
that you just have to lecture on or get
across in some way so um you can make it
work this the seminars I did in the
physics side of things have worked but
the philosophy ones have been a little
bit more you know directly to the The
Sweet Spot of people discussing things
and really being engaged with them and
it has been very interesting you know I
think the one thing that came out of the
philosophical naturalism course a few
things came out of that you know this is
my attempt to teach an upper level
philosophy course that nobody else is
teaching right I mean obviously I can do
philosophy of physics which I did last
year but I was trying to be do something
different that wasn't just secretly
physics right in the philosophy
department so I did naturalism nobody
teaches philosophical naturalism this is
not really a course that you can find
online for the most part there's
probably some exceptions out there I'm
sure that there are but it's not a
standard part of the curriculum which is
arguably a little bit weird since if you
go to the survey of philosophers beliefs
the large majority of them are
naturalists and I think that there are a
lot of questions raised by naturalism uh
some of you know that I organized a
workshop a few years ago on moving
naturalism forward where rather than
rehashing tired old debates about
naturalism versus theism or
supernaturalism or other forms of
non-naturalism we sit down as
naturalists and try to confront our own
problems and that was very much the
spirit of this course that I'm teaching
this year so when you're a naturalist
okay good you're a naturalist so what
what is good and evil to a naturalist do
numbers exist where does Consciousness
come from you know these are all
questions that even naturalists need to
address and I honestly don't think that
they kind of have nearly as well as they
should have and what I discovered among
other things is that it's a fun kind of
course for the students because it cross
Cuts other kinds of courses that they're
taking you know from week to week we
might be doing some epistemology or some
ethics or some metaphysics or some
philosophy of science but they've done
all those things individually in
different courses because they're all
philosophy Majors but they've never put
them all together in a sort of
overarching way you know from start to
finish so I think that's very very
useful for the students the other thing
is you know there are sort of
traditional d otomies in philosophy that
I I come to realize yeah they're real
they actually exist so this is an
oversimplification but within naturalism
there is Kant versus Hume Emanuel Kant
versus David Hume and they're kind of
two personality opposites that show up
in philosophical conclusions a a humean
in forget about there's there's specific
definitions of hum in different contexts
but what I just mean is the the general
idea that the world is a set of things
the world is a set of individual little
events and things happening and when we
look at the world we attribute patterns
to those things right we say oh here's
an atom here's an atom here's another
atom they make a table here is a set of
atoms that sort of persist over time in
a certain pattern that makes a person
there's no fundamental essence of
personhood or tableh or whatever there's
just this sort of emergent higher level
pattern David Hume was the
quintessential e entist whereas Kant
even though a naturalist is much more
sympathetic to Essences and single right
ways you know in the in the case of
morality and ethics we talked about
constructivism and there's a distinction
between humi constructivism and Conan
constructivism humans are likely to say
well every person will construct an
ethical system given their own moral
inclinations and intuitions and so forth
whereas a conent is going to say
everyone constructs their own moral
system but there is only one right way
to do it every rational person will
agree the conans are are much more uh
sympathetic to these absolutes these
Essences these single right answers the
humans are a little bit more approximate
emergence that's all okay and it's
interesting to see that kind of
dichotomy which arguably goes back to
Plato and Aristotle with Plato and Kant
being somewhat sympathetic and Aristotle
and Hume being somewhat sympathetic but
um it's it's educational for me from the
learning the history of philosophy kind
of
perspective Aaron berer says it has been
over 5 years since you started
mindscape how if at all have your goals
for the podcast changed since the
beginning that's a good question I would
honestly say I think it's true that
mostly they haven't in fact surprisingly
little they haven't one of the things
that I find hilarious about people who
listen to the Derek guy uh fashion
podcast is that you know I liked it
better when it was nothing but physics
and if you go back to the
original episodes of mindscape it was
never nothing but physics it was there
was always musicians and actors and
psychologists and things like that on
the podcast so I think that yeah it's
almost surprising to me how little the
goals of the podcast have changed I mean
there's two sets of goals one is to
bring to a wider audience real good
thinkers in various ways I don't always
agree with the thinkers but you know
there is a public what can I say there
is a a public sphere of people who like
to talk about ideas and not all of them
are very good and you know there are
pundits and uh commentators and other
podcasters who just have opinions about
everything and you can get these
opinions and you know some people are
louder than others let's just put it
that way and I very specifically wanted
to make sure that the people who I tried
to BR bring on mindscape were the
careful thinkers the people who really
dig deeply in our experts in some field
not just the loudest talkers not just
the people who had opinions about
everything it's okay to be a loud talker
to be a person who has opinion about
everything as long as you have some
specific area of expertise where you
really expert level deep knowledge and
there's no necessary reason why such
people should always be familiar to
people in the public how would they know
right so that's my job as the podcaster
you know and and I've said this before
but I'm in a happy fortunate situation
where I don't have to make my living
being a podcaster I don't need to
optimize for monetary return so I don't
have to bring on the most famous people
the people whose names you would
instantly recognize sometimes I do if
have something interesting to say but
many times I I I presume it's true that
almost everyone who listens to mindscape
has not heard of all the people that I
have on before I hadn't heard of all of
them before I look around in different
areas I'm like you know man we haven't
done history in a while let's get a
historian on and I you know try to look
for somebody interesting to get on of
course you get a lot of pitches from
people who have books out and that makes
your life easier but many of the guests
I have just are people I found as an
academic who are doing something
interesting so spreading the insights
and what people have to say uh who are
super duper experts who the general
public doesn't get to hear very often is
something that I I definitely have as a
goal um I want more people to hear
people like Elizabeth Anderson who they
might not have ever heard of before the
other goal of course is that I want to
talk to interesting people you know and
I've said this before also but I have a
long pile of books next to my nightstand
that I would like to read read and who
has time to read all the books I have I
have time to read books but not nearly
as many books as I want to read so I get
to talk to experts I get to look through
their books some I read cover to cover
some I just skim through to get enough
questions to ask but I get to ask the
author of these books or the author of
these ideas you know what's going on and
I get all my questions answered and
things like that so uh it's both very
useful to me and very useful to everyone
else somewhat useful to anyone else
anyway and I think that those are the
goals and those pretty much Remain the
goals I hope that uh other people are
enjoying it as much as I
am Jameson says does eternalism mean
that every moment in SpaceTime is
equally real or does it also mean every
moment is equally persistent for example
the current moment has the
distinguishing characteristic that is
happening right now do all other moments
also have this distinguishing
characteristic um I don't even know what
this would mean uh certainly the first
part of the sentence is the right one
every moment is equally real that's what
eternalism says it doesn't even say
every moment in SpaceTime it means every
moment in time the lingo that people use
here is in SpaceTime a point uh is an
event if you have a specific location in
space and moment in time you're an event
a moment in time is a slice through all
of SpaceTime and you can talk about how
slices through SpaceTime are dependent
on the Observer or the coordinate system
or whatever fine but however you do it
however you slice SpaceTime into moments
of time and eternalist will say they are
all equally real no moments of time are
persistent at all I mean persistent
literally means lasting through time and
that's not what moments of time do so I
would I I do not think that every moment
is equally persistent in any sense the
traditional wrong thing to say about
eternalism is every moment exists
simultaneously or every moment exists
now that is not what eternal eternalism
says eternalism just says every moment
is equally real past present or future
and then you say Jameson the current
moment has the distinguishing
characteristic that it's happening right
now I think that that sentence is just
ill formed in some sense because you're
switching from a point of view of inside
the moments happening to outside okay
when you say the current moment is that
the current moment when you typed that
sentence or the current moment when I'm
reading this which current moment are
you talking about to an eternalist every
moment in time has the feature that at
that moment it is happening then and
people who are living in that moment
would say it is happening now but
there's no distinguish there's nothing
to distinguish I suppose I should say
any moment from any other moment all the
moments are created equal Malcolm
McGregor says people talk a lot about
the fine-tuning of physical constants as
if they were variables to be set in a
computer program before running a
simulation of the universe and that if
the constants were only slightly
different than the universe as we know
it would not exist but is it possible
that if we knew the fundamental laws of
nature the values of the constants would
be what they are as a natural
consequence and we would see that they
could not be any other way in the same
way that the value of pi comes about
from the properties of a circle so then
saying if the universe sorry if the
charge on the electron had a different
value then the universe would not exist
would be like saying if the value of pi
was different different then circles
would not exist well you know it's
possible longtime listeners know
whenever you ask a physics question
beginning with the phrase is it possible
that the answer is always going to be
yes it is possible however we have
absolutely no reason to think that that
particular possibility is true we have a
huge distinction conceptually between
numbers that appear in the laws of
nature like Newton's constant of gravity
or the fine structure constant versus
mathematical constants that are
Universal and everybody would agree on
it is very very easy for us to imagine
alternative worlds where the value of
the fine structure constant was a little
bit different where the mass of the
neutron is a little bit less than the
mass of the proton instead of Vice Versa
we cannot imagine a universe in which
the value of pi as conventionally
defined comes about in to be any other
value than it does that's a very
important difference now so I'm going to
I'm going to be negative toward that
particular scenario that you're
proposing but let me be positive toward
the underlying question here which is
how should we be talking about the
fine-tuning of physical constants as you
say people talk about them as if they
were variables to be set in a computer
program my personal belief and this is a
a future research project that I
absolutely every intention of doing um I
don't think that talk about values that
the constants of nature could and should
have in anything like a sensible way I
do think that we have to do it in some
sense in the same sense that we have to
talk about counterfactuals more
generally um when we talk about the
universe we do more than simply say this
happened and this happened and this
happened we say things like if things
have been different then this would have
happened that's the origin of talk of
causation and reasons why things happen
because in this other Universe where X
didn't happen y would not have happened
right and so we should be allowed to
talk about the fundamental physical
constants in the same way the problem is
a little bit in ordinary counterfactuals
and very much in the physical constants
context we don't have a good measure on
the space of possibilities it is not
true that our universe is randomly
chosen from some from some set of
possible physical constants we don't
know whether there is some underlying
reason why the physical constants were
likely to have the value they did or
whether there is just some arbitrariness
in the way the world Works maybe there's
some Multiverse where different things
look different in different parts of the
universe or whatever we just don't know
so we're in this weird situation where
we need to talk about this idea and we
have no idea how to do it so I would
like to improve that situation maybe
it'll be impossible possible but that's
certainly a goal Georgio says is the
concept of time we know and love
necessary to be going sorry necessarily
going to be the same as the parameter we
often label as t with respect to which
the wave function of the universe
evolves I love this question because the
answer is no it doesn't need necessarily
need to be the same thing maybe it turns
out to be the same thing so for just to
back up to make sure everyone's on the
same page here uh I've often said that
the most fundamental equation we know
about in physics is the schinger
equation the wave function of the
universe evolves with respect to some
hamiltonian that tells us what the
energy of the wave function is and the
hamiltonian times the wave function
tells us the derivative the time
derivative the rate of change of the
wave function so there is a parameter T
called the time that appears right there
in the shinger equation but as you know
quantum gravity is a tricky subject we
don't know exactly how the real world
that you and I experience emerges from
that wave function of the universe so is
it possible that the time we measure on
our clocks is different than the time
that appears in that AB in that
Universal shinger equation yes it's
absolutely possible there are even hints
from things like the ads CFT
correspondence and string theory that
the same underlying Quantum Evolution
can correspond to two different very
classical space times two very different
classical spacetimes where time is
measured differently in one than in the
other so I don't know what the right
answer is here is but I do think we
should be open-minded about those
possibilities Michael shillingford says
what accounts for objects being more
than conventional or non-anthropocentric
in your ontology in something deeply
hidden you say these things would exist
even without humans but I'm not sure the
finer details well you know at some
level this is just a good question and a
tricky one and no one has the exact
answer to it when things should be said
to exist my rough answer comes from
Daniel dennet former mindscape guest
when in his notion of real patterns I'm
not exactly sure that my understanding
of dennett's real patterns is the same
as dennett's understanding but my
understanding is that you you have a
bunch of things happening in the
universe you have a physical system
called reality whatever it is but you
don't know everything about reality you
have incomplete information there are
certain circumstances in which
you can say very informative predictive
things about the universe even though
you don't have complete information so
if I tell you I have a table let's say I
have a dining room table then you would
instantly infer that I could put a plate
on that table and it would not fall
through now I did not tell you what
every atom in the table was you know
from the idea of a table that it has
certain properties so the fact that
there are things called tables is a
persistent higher level real pattern in
the ontology of the world there is
nothing there that requires the
existence of human beings or knowledge
or Consciousness or anything like that
there is a pattern that can be picked
out now whether or not there are people
doing the picking out is a different
question but the existence of the
pattern is absolutely real and objective
and independent of human
beings Christian Rodarte says priority
question if all matter has some
rudimentary form of experience do you
think it's possible we could remember
things that happened during the Big Bang
like biogenesis it's crackpot but if
creation myth myths and stories were
symbolic of what happened during the Big
Bang it would be poetic well like we
said if your question is is it possible
yes it's always possible however once
again in this case I think it's
completely implausible that all matter
has a r rudimentary form of experience I
think we have zero evidence for that
plenty of evidence against it so I I
don't know how to answer questions of
the form if this false thing were true
what would happen you know uh if you if
you want an answer to this question you
would have to talk to somebody who
thinks that it is plausible that all
matter has a rudimentary form of
experience and then maybe they have
further consequences of that to me I get
off the train right there so I can't say
much more about
it Jeff H asks another priority question
as you fall toward a black hole from
your perspective does time dilation
cause Hawking radiation to Blue shift
ASM totically the closer you get another
words are black holes white holes in
slow
motion well this is a good question but
uh the different parts of it have
different statuses here the in other
words has kind of thrown a monkey into
the wrench um black holes are not white
holes in slow motion that is just not
true a white hole is not just something
that glows and gives off radiation a
white white hole is literally and
explicitly the time reverse of a black
hole so a black hole is something that
you can fall into and never escape a
white hole is something you can escape
from but never fall into a white hole
has a singularity in the past black
holes have singularities in the future
so there's zero sense in which black
holes are white holes in slow motion now
there is a tricky and complicated
technical question about what you see as
you fall into a black hole in fact I
have a student working to improve our
current understanding of this because
our current understanding is just not
that good right now to be honest um
roughly speaking you don't see more and
more high energy radiation as you fall
into the black hole uh what you see is
almost nothing you don't see anything
special as you cross the Event Horizon
of a black hole Now The Details Matter
here and the details are tricky because
if you're standing far away from the
black hole the typ typical wavelength of
radiation you see is comparable to the
short Shield distance the short Shield
radius of the black hole so a small
black hole will have um short wavelength
radiation high temperature a big black
hole has long wavelength radiation low
temperature and so when you're near the
Event Horizon if it's a big black hole
if it's much bigger than you then you
don't have enough time to observe
radiation at all right because the
radiation is on wavelengths much larger
than you and on time scales much longer
than your falling into the black hole
time so it becomes a very non-trivial
question you can't just imagine standing
at the Event Horizon and asking what you
see you're not allowed to stand at the
Event Horizon so what you instead have
to do is some complicated thing where
you literally model falling in on some
trajectory with a particle detector and
turning on the detector and turning off
the detector and then making sure that
what you're observing when when you do
that is actually from the black hole not
from the particle detector that you
turned on and turned off so it is a
subtle question but the short quick
answer is that as far as we know you do
not see you know ASM totically brighter
and brighter higher and higher energy
radiation as you fall into the black
hole Pete Newton says I've heard you say
that the universe is approximately flat
and expansion happens most in the large
Open Spaces all the systems I know of
that undergo self-organization from
protein folding to nuclear Decay do it
to be in a lower energy State finally if
you stretch a curve it becomes flatter
so could dark energy be caused by the
universe trying to flatten to be in a
lower more stable energy State there's a
clever idea but the answer is no that is
not what is going on um there's a couple
of things to keep in mind here one is
the motto that systems undergoing
self-organization go to a lower energy
state is not quite right of course
energy is conserved in these processes
right when you have protein folding
nuclear Decay and so forth the total
energy before is exactly equal to the
total energy after what's really going
on is dissipation the system that you
care about is giving off energy in the
form of the parts of the system you
don't care about whether it's sound or
heat light or you know low energy
photons things like that so there's a
that process is actually characterized
by increasing entropy it's the
increasing entropy that is most
important not going to lower energy
because energy is
conserved now the case of the expanding
Universe the the entropy is indeed
increasing but the idea that it is
trying to flatten is not quite right in
fact what it's trying to do is to empty
out that's true and what the empty state
will look like depends on the value of
the vacuum energy depends on the value
of the cosmological constant what's
important about our current universe is
the value of the cosmological constant
is very very tiny on the scale of
physical parameters that we might
imagine so therefore the state that
we're approaching looks pretty flat but
if the cosmal constant were large which
it absolutely could be then even the
empty space state of the universe would
still have a large amount of curvature
now the F the final complication here
just to be completely honest is that
you have to distinguish between the
geometry of space versus the geometry of
space time okay when I say the universe
is approximately flat I'm talking about
the geometry of space in cosmology where
you under where you look at the
approximation where things are
homogeneous and isotropic on very large
scales then there's this well-known fact
that if the geometry of space the
three-dimensional geometry of space is
homogeneous and isotropic
then it's either going to be positively
curved negatively curved or flat and the
observations tend to tell us that it is
flat or at least very close to Flat that
is not to say that the geometry of space
time is flat because the expansion rate
of the universe also contributes to the
geometry of SpaceTime so at Early times
when the expansion rate was very large
space was flat but space time very much
was not at late times like now space
space is still flat space time is much
closer to being flat because it's become
dilute and emptier as the universe has
expanded Aston Nobel says we always
distinguish four fundamental forces and
many attempts have been taken to unify
them first by clua and Klein with
electromagnetism and gravitation later
by Weinberg and Salam who successfully
described the electro weak Force why do
we never speak about electricity and
magnetism as separate fundamental forces
and Maxwell is the one who succeeded to
find a unified description for them uh
well we do we do all the time buy my
upcoming book on Quant and Fields and
you will read exactly those words um
Maxwell's unification of electricity and
magnetism was one of the first early
examples of a successful unification in
physics we don't talk about them in
exactly the same footing because that
unification was what eventually led us
to invent special relativity to think of
SpaceTime in a relativistic way and once
you have relativity once you are
immersed in that way of thinking then
electricity and magnetism are
automatically unified you don't need to
work hard they just are different
versions of the same underlying thing in
exactly the same way that space and time
are different versions of the same
underlying thing whereas the unification
that Weinberg and Salam did or Kus and
Clyde are trying to do they are all
presuming relativity from the start and
trying to do some particle physics based
unification from imagining that there's
a single underlying symmetry that gives
rise to these apparently different
forces so it's not because of Relativity
that these extra unification attempts
are happening it's a separate symmetry
breaking kind of thing when and if they
actually do
work GS says what do you think the path
to normaly looks like for the American
democracy even if a Democrat Progressive
candidate wins the 2024 election it's
clear not much progress can be made
without control of the Senate and House
of Representatives as well this is a
long question so I edited some I do
encourage all questioners to make their
questions short they don't listen to me
but I encourage you to do that anyway
the question continues I'm honestly
feeling very hopeless so much real world
harm has been done in just the last few
years and even if I vote in every
election the next decade I feel like the
odds are just stacked against those of
us who want to live in a more fair kind
and Progressive Society is the path to
this Society just to keep voting until
all the obstacles mentioned above are
overcome even if that might take decades
if it even happens at all well you know
the short answer here is I wish I knew
uh how to get American democracy back to
normal healthy functioning I don't think
it's has anything directly to do with
voting for Democrats or Progressive
candidates you know you could you should
do that I am pretty Democratic
Progressive myself um and and they as of
right now as of 2023 uh the Democratic
party is much more in favor of
traditional literal lowercase D
democracy than the Republican party is
but that's not the underlying issue the
underlying issue is that a lot of people
in the United States aren't that much
impressed with democracy they think that
they're could be a better system they
think that uh their party being
perpetually in charge would be better I
think that protecting the health of
democracy does not come down to voting
for this or that party but but for
convincing other people in the country
that democracy is a good thing I think
this is an aspect of living in a
democracy which has been underemphasized
in recent years we look at the results
we look at who is elected What policies
they have we forget about the fact that
the whole point of living in a democracy
is the people who are citizens of the
country are supposed to be the ultimate
Authority from which the government
derives its Authority and so if you want
people to do good things you convince
the people it's good to vote it's good
to run for office if you want to do that
it's good to campaign for your favorite
people uh but you also have to talk to
other citizens you also have to convince
people that it's okay to lose
elections sometimes a democracy only
works if you're willing to lose
elections and I think you this is not
just about the United States I think
this is true for any burgeoning
democracy if you if are if you are a
country that recently over through an
autocracy or a monarchy or a
dictatorship and you say well look we
we've had an election and the people who
won the election are now governing the
country we have a democracy I would say
no you don't not yet you have a
democracy when the party or person who
is in power loses an election they
wanted to win and hands over power to
the opposition that's when you have a
functioning democracy and I think that
we need to think that's okay pay in some
very real sense we need to uh people on
all sides I think people more on one
side than the other but people on all
sides need to be willing to talk to each
other to listen to what each other has
to say to try to persuade other people
because that's the foundation of an
actual working democracy I have no
specific ways of making that happen but
I do think that's what we should work
toward soonest mended says I know you
don't have kids but if you did what are
some big picture Concepts that you would
want to be sure to teach them it's a
little open-ended this question I'm not
quite sure what kind of Concepts you
mean do you mean like conservation of
energy or do you mean you know how to be
a good person I'm not sure I do think
that how to be a good person is a more
important concept than uh conservation
of energy and related to the question I
just answered about democracy you know I
think that taking other
people's desires and values into
consideration as a person listening to
other people uh is perhaps one of the
most important skills that we can have
um really accepting that other people
can be different than us and that's okay
as long as they're not hurting us right
um there was just as I'm recording this
there was just this little conversation
on Blue Sky earlier about Derek parfit
Derek parfit is a very famous um
philosopher who died a few years ago and
he was one of these people who sometimes
you see in not just Academia but High
High um high achievement people in in
various forms who was kind of a jerk he
was kind of a jerk to his loved ones and
friends and family because you know uh
he had a friend I guess a former
relationship a former loved one who was
dying of cancer and went to visit him
just to say goodbye and he didn't have
any time to talk to her he said I'm
writing my book leave me alone I don't
that you're dying of cancer and my
response to that is you know that's his
choice like I don't think I don't want
to be him if I had my kids I would not
want to teach my kids to be like that
but I would want to teach my kids to
accept people like that to not try to
make every person just like yourself
right I think that's one of the most
important things we can teach people I
would also like to teach kids to you
know be curious and be honest and have
integrity and help others and and all
sorts of different things but um
different you know the thing about human
beings even if they're kids are they're
individual human beings they're going to
do what they want to do at the end of
the day we have to give them a good
environment and let them become who
they're going to
become Rob patro says You seem
incredibly productive from the
perspective of an academic whose's
interested in doing more public Outreach
and generating more highquality content
for people interested in learning more
about my field I find the sheer amount
diversity and quality of the content you
produce to be incredible I'm curious if
you have a specific strategy or method
for getting things done well thank you
Rob I appreciate that but I don't feel
incredibly productive myself I I feel
that like there's all these other things
I want to do that I don't have time to
do so that's the you know version of of
uh my feelings about my productivity
that that is foremost in my mind but no
I don't have a method I don't have a
specific strategy you know it reminds me
of I I for a few years back in La I was
working with a personal trainer I would
go to the gym and you know there's a
thing you sign up so you get personal
training lessons and he's a very nice
guy and you know he would help me out
and he once told me the story of you
know he had a group of friends and they
decided to like in general do
self-improvement and help each other do
self-improvement and so they asked him
because he's a personal trainer they
said help us get motivated to go to the
gym and work out all the time and
exercise and he gave what I thought was
a very insightful answer which is he
said I am the last person who should
help you with this because I don't need
motivation to go to the gym and work out
and exercise that's what I like to do
that's what I would do left to my own
devices I'm not the person who will help
you overcome a reluctance and I think
about that when you ask this question
because uh and again I'm very very
fortunate and privileged to be in this
situation but I do the things I like
doing I like doing scientific research I
like doing philosophical research I like
making the podcast I like writing books
uh I like doing all sorts of things
giving talks and I also like the fact
that I get to do all of them I wouldn't
be happy if I were only doing one of
these things and I know a lot of people
there sort of basins of Attraction where
you try to do many things but one of
them works out the best for you and and
you end up doing nothing but that I am
just a different kind of person I'm
happiest when I can do a little bit of
all these kinds of things so I don't
really need a strategy or method uh to
get the things done that I get done and
you know these are my hobbies these are
the things that bring me joy these are
the things that I uh would do left to my
own devices so I don't need to sort of
strategize I still feel bad when I'm
like late for a deadline or or whatever
um or I'm Ill prepared for a podcast you
know I feel bad all the time
but uh I don't need to motivate myself
to do these things because it's what I
would rather be doing than most other
things that I would do so if you're not
like that uh I'm not sure what to say I
mean I guess the general strategy would
be find a way to sort of
optimize what you want to get done
versus what you intrinsically like to do
you know try not to swim against the
current too much uh that's my secret for
getting things done Define as the things
you want to get done the things that you
would like to be doing and there then
then you'll be a success at
that Getty Lee smolen says I can't find
exactly where but I think you said
something along the lines of the laws of
nature are patterns which we can learn
about through hypothesis testing and
observation I don't remember exactly
saying that but that sounds like
something I would
say does this change if you're a lassan
demon or omnicient being do the laws of
physics become like the rules of a video
game immutable and hardwired into the
fabric of reality Yes actually they do
um if you're lassus demon then the way
in which you think about the universe is
very very different remember I talked
about those real patterns about tables
and chairs and things like that lassus
demon need not know that there is such a
thing as a table or a chair right
because lassus demon knows all the
information tables and chairs become
interesting and important when you have
incomplete information so lassus demon
only needs to know the most fundamental
level of reality and from that
everything follows and that's very
different way of thinking than you or I
are thinking um I don't necessarily
think if if if the implication of your
question is that uh lassus demon or an
omnicient being would see the laws of
nature as
inevitable then that I don't think is
necessarily true at all um I think that
again we can imagine different laws of
physics different laws of nature so
lassus demon would know that the world
Works in this way and not in that way um
but it would absolutely know what those
rules are at the deepest possible
level Liam mccardy says in your book The
Big Picture you say the laws of physics
underlying everyday life life are
completely known in other words the core
theory is and will forever more be
correct in its domain of applicability
which encompasses everyday life might
there be however complex dynamics that
begin outside that domain and yet
ultimately affect everyday life could a
proverbial butterfly which flaps its
wings in a domain beyond our current
experimental reach cause a proverbial
tornado in the domain within our
reach guess what Liam you have asked a
question of the form is it possible that
and the answer is yes it is possible
that that might very well be as usual
that is not where I would stop the
questioning what I would ask is given
what we know about the universe How
likely is it to be true that this kind
of thing is there and in the big picture
and in other ways of talking about this
I do not simply say the laws of physics
underlying everyday life are completely
known I provide the reasons for thinking
that namely that the fundamental laws of
physics in the regimes that we're
talking about seem to run according to
the rules of quantum field Theory indeed
Quantum field theory is more or less the
only rules that are possible if you
believe in things like special
relativity quantum mechanics locality
things like that and if the laws of
quantum field Theory are true in the
ways that we current currently
understand them then no then the complex
dynamics that begin outside that domain
will not ultimately affect everyday life
it is a conclusion that the laws of
physics underlying everyday life are
completely known not an assumption or a
guess or a suggestion given certain very
strong beliefs that we have about how
the world works it follows that the laws
of physics are completely known so
that's okay there's plenty of other
things that we don't know we don't know
the laws of physics underneath the level
of everyday life we don't know
non-physics laws like chemistry or
biology or whatever plenty of work still
to be done in science and other areas of
human endeavor Roy Thompson asks is
there a symmetry or other proposed
reason why the imbalance in matter and
antimatter quarks and the imbalance in
matter and antimatter leptons ended in
an elect Ally neutral universe or local
Universe at least well it's absolutely
possible that there is a reason it's
also possible that it's an accident so
here's what we think we know if space
again space not SpaceTime
threedimensional space is compact so if
space is a three-dimensional sphere or
Taurus or something like that then the
rules of electromagnetism say there must
be exactly zero net electric charge in
the universe the way you can think about
that is if you have a single electric
charge there are lines of electric force
that go out from that charge to infinity
and there's a rule gauss's law that you
can integrate up the electric field at
Infinity to figure out how much charge
is inside but if space is compact then
there is no such thing as Infinity right
there's just the whole universe you have
those electric lines of force they would
have to go and meet themselves somewhere
else in the universe and that would be
an opposite charge a positive charge if
you would started with a negative charge
Etc so in a closed Universe the electric
charge has to be exactly zero if it's
not closed if the universe is not closed
then it doesn't have to be exactly zero
it can be some other number but there's
no reason why that we can think of it
shouldn't be zero either so this is not
generally thought of as a big puzzle as
far as modern physics is concerned but
we don't know precisely the situation
yet
XLR wrrp o90 says how do
experimentalists get their hands on
particles they haven't decohered with
presumably they decohered with their
apparatus before the experiment began so
I'm not exactly sure what this question
is about but let me again try to say
some true things um one true thing is
that we often in the universe work under
the assumption that we are not entangled
with other things and that is an
assumption but it's a good assumption
for good physical reasons for example
you are not entangled with the chair
you're sitting on for example you're
sitting on it you're interacting with it
but if there was some Quantum state that
entangled you with the chair that would
mean that you different parts of your
wave function were connected to
different parts of the chair's wave
function now in principle in the wave
function of the universe that very well
might be true but because both you and
the chair are big macroscop IC things
you would quickly also become entangled
with the environment and that means from
an never eding perspective that you
would Branch the universe and there
would be one branch of the universe
where you and the chair were doing one
thing another Branch where you and the
chair were doing another thing and on
those individual branches there is no
more entanglement between you and the
chair now an elementary particle is not
a chair it is not a big macroscopic
object so the question how do
experimentalists get their hands on
particles they haven't decohered with
for one thing I'm not even sure what the
word decohered with means the phrase
decohered with you don't decohere with
something a Quantum state is either
coherent or decoherent so to decohere
means become entangled with the
environment so maybe probably what you
mean is how do you get your hands on
particles that you're not entangled with
um in that case well you start with a
particle and then you measure it and as
soon as you measure it you're no longer
entangled you've seen some experimental
outcome so for example it's most clear
if you just think about the spin of a
particle and you want to say people will
often say start with a particle that is
spin up and you might very well ask well
how do you know that the particle is
spin up the answer is you measure it you
measure the spin if it's down you throw
it away and try again if it's up now you
have a particle that is spin up and you
can do with it whatever you
want Tyler smucker says out of all the
great progressive rock albums from the '
60s and70s what are some of your
favorites you know I thought about this
uh when you asked the question I'm not a
great like ranker of albums or anything
like that uh you know I have my
favorites but I don't insist that one is
the best Etc and I love progressive rock
but you know these guys generally did
tend to have both high points and low
points on the Same album so I'm going to
say something like fragile is an obvious
choice by yes but they have those Dopey
little solo parts of fragile fragile had
these group compositions and
performances that were amazing that were
great heart of the sunrise roundabout
Southside of the sky Etc but then they
also had you know apparently they were
short of money and they had just
replaced their keyboard player they
kicked out Tony Kay invited in Rick
Wakeman and they needed to pay for Rick
Wakeman's new keyboards so they needed
to bang out an album as quickly as
possible in order to pay for his
keyboards and it was quicker to let each
band member record a little solo piece
to fill up the album rather than to
actually just write a song and and
record it so that makes it a very kind
of disappointing effort especially
because they had just recorded a cover
version of Simon and Garfunkle um
America which was an amazing cover
version they could have just put that on
the album I think anyway I'm remembering
the time timing correctly so that would
have been a perfect album but they
didn't do that um elps albums at the
early days I love all of them and they
all have weak points maybe Trilogy might
be my favorite one there I think that uh
is you know has the least of the sort of
indulgent instrumentals that Keith
Emerson loved so much and uh the first
King Crimson album also a classic many
many Classics back then and I make no
pretense to being up on what the kids
are listening to these days I'm sure
there's just as good music coming out
now as there was when I first started
listening to music seriously in high
school and college but I don't know what
it is and I'm got other things on my
mind there you go Cubit says you said
that the preferred basis problem of many
worlds disappears when thinking in terms
of density matrices since we only have
to find the basis in which the density
Matrix of the of Interest becomes
diagonal however this cannot be the
final answer when we talk about many
worlds and the wave function of the
universe simultaneously in this case
there is no well-defined subsystem with
respect to which we can trace the
environment and therefore the density
Matrix represents a pure state with
seemingly only a single world how do we
defi how do we find the preferred basis
in this case apologies to people who are
not experts at Quantum Mechanics for
this question but it's especially
interesting question that I think it's
worth uh a stab at answering it the the
very short answer is this is a really
important problem it's an open problem
and I write papers about it so you can
look up my paper with ashme Singh on
Quantum
mology where we talk about exactly this
problem how do you divide up the world
into a system and environment so that
you can find a preferred basis for just
the envir just the system rather so the
the basic physics idea here is that
again since we're not lass's demon we
coar grain our descriptions of the
universe and one of the ways that we do
this in quantum mechanics is to divide
the world into systems that we keep
track of and environments that we don't
keep track of now often in practice this
is just kind of obvious right here's a
cat that's the system but then all the
photons of light in the room that are
bouncing off the cat those are the
environment we're not keeping track of
all those okay if you're doing schinger
cat experiment but you would like to do
better than that especially if you're
interested in the foundations of quantum
mechanics you'd like a principled
algorithm for figuring out how to divide
the quantum State into system and
environment and so ashme and I proposed
such an algorithm the quantum mology
algorithm for doing exactly that and
basically it's based on the idea that
you want to find a decomposition such
that the system can have a classical
limit so that it can behave
fundamentally classically and there's a
set of criteria that you can put in to
make that happen and it ends up that the
system looks kind of classical looking
the environment looks kind of
environment looking with a bunch of um
easily manipulated low energy degrees of
freedom now just to be super clear uh I
certainly have never said that the
preferred basis problem disappears
because the preferred basis problem is a
good problem I think it's solved but it
doesn't disappear and even when it's
solved it's not just find the basis in
which the density Matrix of Interest
becomes diagonal the density Matrix for
those of you who are not experts is how
we talk about the quantum state of a
subsystem that is entangled with the
rest of the world okay if two things are
not entangled you can talk about the
wave function of a subsystem but if they
are entangled the density Matrix is the
thing that keeps track of as much
information as you can keep track of
without knowing what the rest of the
world is
doing and it will always be true that if
you have an entangled system so you have
a density Matrix that describes it you
can diagonalize that density Matrix you
can find a basis in which the density
Matrix looks like a diagonal Al Matrix
but that's not the point that's just a
trivial mathematical fact the important
physical fact is that you can figure out
ahead of time that once the system
becomes entangled with its environment
the system's density Matrix will become
diagonal in a predefined basis so this
is exactly scher's cat okay this is the
question why when you look at the cat is
it always either the awake cat or the
asleep cat not 1/ > two awake plus
asleep or 1/ of2 awake minus asleep the
answer is because the states that Define
definite spatial
configurations are the ones in which the
density Matrix will become diagonal you
know that ahead of time you don't need
to just have the density Matrix and
diagonalize it why do they become
diagonal because the environmental
degrees of freedom the photons Etc
become entangled separately they become
entangled differently with the the
different macroscopic configurations of
the cat or what other any other
macroscopic system you may have so you
this this is all work this is all stuff
you have to figure out and I don't think
that the state-of-the-art is complete
and finished yet but we kind of see the
outline for how it will all be settled
once we understand everything
perfectly Nomad 666 says I've been
hearing about JW's new data and can you
tell me what's going on with the mystery
of the Hubble constant tension
yeah I actually just uh got lucky enough
a couple days ago to sit in on a
colloquium at John's Hopkins by Adam ree
Adam of course is Nobel prizewinning
observational astronomer former
mindscape guest and last but not least
my colleague at Johns Hopkins so we
unfortunately had a uh last minute
cancellation in the colloquium series
and Adam agreed to step in and talk
about the Hubble tension the Hubble
tension which we talked about on the
podcast with Adam if you want to go
check that out that was from a couple
years ago but but basically it's not
gone away it's just gotten worse and
what I mean by worse is the following
the Hubble parameter you know we call it
the constant but of course we all know
the Hubble constant changes over time so
it's a parameter in our cosmological
model and it's a physical thing that we
can measure okay so these are two
different aspects of the Hubble
parameter one is you can just measure
the velocities and distances to galaxies
and Hubble's Law says velocity of
distant galaxies is Hubble parameter
times distance so if you get a bunch of
galaxies you plot them on a straight
line and you fit the slope you've
measured the Hubble parameter good for
you but there's a whole other thing you
can do which is you can start with a
model of the overall evolution of the
universe our favorite model these days
is the famous Lambda CDM model a model
based on general relativity and
scale-free density perturbations at
Early times or nearly scale free plus uh
matter radiation Dark Matter
cosmological constant and within that
model you have different parameters that
pin down which version of the model
you're looking at what exactly is the
density of dark matter what exactly is
the amplitude of density fluctuations
what is the current Hubble constant okay
the current Hubble
parameter and that model can be measured
its parameters can be pinned down by all
sorts of different cosmological
observations such as the cosmic
microwave background large scale
structure what we call Baron
oscillations the different amount of
structure in visible matter at different
wavelengths gravitational lensing a
whole bunch of different kinds of
measurements and so from that model
fitting you can ask what is the value of
the Hubble parameter that you need to
best fit the model and these two methods
one is the direct method using galaxies
and sephi variables and Supernova
relatively nearby the other are these
kinds of global methods where you fit to
the model these two methods disagree
that's the Hubble tension the direct
measurement method gives you about 72
for the Hubble constant as a number the
uh Cosmic microwave background
measurements from the plon satellite and
elsewhere give you about
67 these are pretty close and you know
when I was your age we didn't even know
whether the Hubble constant was 50 or
100 so we had factors of two
discrepancies and now we're on 10%
discrepancies but still compared to the
error bars that we expect to have the
experiment the discrepancy is
statistically significant at a level of
more than five Sigma to you scientists
out there which is very very significant
and Adam gave a very good talk where he
just went through all of the ways that
the local measurements which is what he
does for a living could be wrong all the
sources of error Etc and he made a
persuasive case that they're not wrong
that we've you know we have various
sources of possible error we checked all
of them
um basically the
measurements so the the the new wrinkle
that we have now that we didn't have
when we did the podcast is some new
measurements from the James web Space
Telescope so here's a little bit of uh
in the weeds for you astronomy fans out
there so we're trying to measure the
local value of the Hubble constant by
looking at actual expansion of the
universe in our neighborhood now our
neighborhood still means you know
millions and millions of light years
okay but it's just not the whole Global
University once kind of thing so we're
looking at at pretty high red shifts
compared to our Milky Way or something
like that anyway you use a kind of
traditional Cosmic distance ladder the
cosmic distance ladder is what you need
to do because you can't measure
distances directly what you can do is
look at a supernova in a distant Galaxy
and Supernova are very good
standardizable candles so you know that
all the different Supernova you can
reduce to a common brightness given
their light curve shape and things like
that what you don't know is exactly what
that brightness is but what you can try
to do is find Supernova in galaxies
where you also have what are called
sephi variable stars stars that pulsate
with a given period and
luminosity and over a century ago
henrieta levit showed that there's a
relationship in sephi variables between
their period and their intrinsic
Luminosity so again they are
standardizable candles so you can figure
out you can relate the brightness of the
of the sehid variables to the um
brightness of the Supernova in the same
galaxies now still you don't know the
absolute brightness of the sephi
variables but there there are some sephi
variables that are very nearby and you
can basically use parallax literally the
geometry the fact that a nearby star
moves a little bit in its apparent
location on the sky when the earth is on
one side of the Sun versus The Other
Side of the Sun so that's a direct
geometric measure of the distance so he
goes from Parallax to seids to Supernova
and what jwst has done is improved our
pre Precision at measuring these sepid
variables among other things but this is
one of the things that Adam was excited
about and was talking about so it's it's
kind of interesting like I'm a
theoretical physicist what do I know
about this so it's interesting to see
the real good um observers at work you
can take an observation of these seid
variables with the Hubble Space
Telescope which was of course
unprecedentedly good in its day but
sometimes you got a little bit of error
because the sephi variable you're
looking at the literal number of pixels
that it took up in the camera overlapped
with other nearby Stars it was hard
because you're literally looking at
stars in other galaxies they're very far
away it could be sometimes hard to get
nonoverlapping completely separate
pictures of the seate variables so this
was a known source of potential error
and now with with jwst you have higher
resolution so you can actually move
remove the or sorry you can distinguish
between the seied variable you care
about and the other stars that are
nearby so you apparently from what Adam
says you get the same answer either way
but of course you're now more confident
in your answer because you have removed
that particular source of error so he
went through a list of like 10 different
possible sources of error this was one
of them but you know there many
different sources and he painted a good
case that we know what we're doing so
I'm actually relatively willing to
believe that the Hubble tension is a
real tension um the question is what how
to how to resolve it and there there's
basically two camps if the Hubble
tension is real so if measuring
or yeah measuring the Hubble parameter
by local measurements versus model
fitting of the whole universe if you
really get different answers there's two
possibilities that obviously come to
mind one is there's something subtle
about the evolution of structure in the
universe that we are getting wrong okay
um in other words within the known laws
of physics but when considering all of
the tricky details of the origin of
density perturbations and their
evolution something has gone wrong so
that uh We've measured the local Hubble
constant correctly but our figuring out
what that parameter should be in the
context of Lambda CDM is somehow making
a mistake I have no idea what what this
mistake would be I'm not an expert at
that but I think it's legitimately on
the
table the other big obvious exciting
possibility is that there's something
wrong with the laws of physics there's
some new physics going on and people um
like my other Hopkins colleague Mark KY
and Kowski have been very active in
proposing models for what that could be
maybe there was a temporary period of
dark energy in the early Universe over
and above the dark energy we see today
maybe there are some effects of magnetic
fields in the early universe that we
don't know about um maybe the universe
is tilted or you know something some
kind of there's like neutrinos or hot
dark matter in addition to cold dark
matter all sorts of different
possibilities are being looked at none
of them none of the Thousand Papers
written uh the propos models for this
have yet kind of stood up and said yes
look I'm obviously the right answer so
as far as I can see this is still a good
question we're still thinking about it
that's what makes cosmology
fun Arie moscowitz says I am a
96-year-old male fellow atheist in good
health my doctor says I will make a 100
my atheism allows me to enjoy life with
little fear of the end imagine you are a
96-year-old atheist what advice would
you give fellow Nigerians
Jans um sorry Arie I'm not exactly sure
whether you're asking me what you are
literally asking what advice would I
give to
nonagenarians versus
specifically uh what advice would I give
to atheist nonagenarians or maybe what
you're asking is as an atheist what
advice would I give to non- atheist
nonagenarians uh in any case you know
I'm probably not the guy to be giving
advice to nonagenarians i i i
congratulate you on living such a uh
long and fruitful life and uh on being a
a happy and and fulfilled atheist you
know I I'm not going to
downplay the reality of mortality and
how important it is um we're all Mortal
it's going to happen and as naturalists
as atheists we think that the life that
we have is the whole shebang there's not
anything that comes after that
um I mean it sounds just glib and simple
and unhelpful but you know accept that
and not only accept it but relish it is
my advice so much as I could possibly
say um what we do here on Earth is what
matters and someday that's going to come
to an end you know uh it's absolutely
possible not to get more of bit about it
but it's possible Arie that you will
outlive me because I don't know how long
I'm going to live we we don't have that
view of the future so all of us need to
be aware that um we should both that we
have to simultaneously to live a good
life um think about and imagine our
future accomplishments and activities
and make sure that what we have already
done is pretty good right you can't live
your life only planning for the future
but you can't live your life not
planning for the future either so you
know I don't like to live in the past or
the future or the present I like to live
in all of these simultaneously that's
what my uh eternalist sympathies lean me
toward so so it's perfectly okay to look
over your long 96y old life it's also
still perfectly okay to you know say
well I got a few years left let's write
a book let's learn how to play the piano
I don't know let's learn a foreign
language it's absolutely like four years
or 10 or 14 years whatever you get
that's a long time you can do a lot
learn quantum mechanics um look forward
to your life however much there is left
as well as enjoying uh reminiscing about
the life if you've already
lived Anthony KN says suppose I set my
credences according to the borne rule to
be 90% spin up and 10% spin down for
some particle that I'm going to measure
but I happen to be mistaken about how
the state was prepared the amplitudes
are actually reversed what could I
observe on the many worlds
interpretation that would clue me into
the fact that I was wrong about the
state if I understand right it can't
come down to the frequency of outcomes
uh actually it can come down to the
frequency of outcomes the philosophy of
many worlds is different but the place
you end up is exactly the same as in a
Copenhagen likee interpretation what I
mean by that is what many world says is
that if you literally do have um a spin
with a certain amplitude squared for
spin up a certain amplitude squared for
spin down both branches of the wave
function will come into being according
to the shinger equation you will have
some self-locating uncertainty as to
which branch you are on once that
measurement has happened and the
argument that I make and I made it with
chip seans and there's other people who
made similar arguments is you should
assign a Credence to being on the
different branches that is given by the
amplitude squared given by the born Rule
now that's a philosophical justification
for assigning those credences but once
they are assigned everything is
completely normal so as chip and I say
in our paper that you're are encouraged
to read what about you know basian
Theory confirmation how does it work in
this context and the answer is it works
exactly the same way as it always works
if you have a spin that you think is 90%
likely to be spin up and 10% spin down
do many measurements on it and if you
find that most of the measurements are
spinned down then you should contemplate
two possibilities one is you got the
credences wrong for whatever reason
right you were mistaken how the state
was prepared or something like that that
is absolutely
possibility another possibility is that
you just got unlucky and as a good
basian the chance that you just got
unlucky should go down the more you do
this kind of experiment over and over
again so in that sense at the end of the
day the accumulation of evidence does
come down to the frequency of outcomes
now the thing that gets some people
upset about this is there will be some
people in the Multiverse in the whole
wave function of the universe who will
come to the wrong conclusion they will
decide that the born rule isn't right
even though it is for other observers
and the answer is yes that you know
there's just going to be some people
will be unlucky there's always a chance
that some people will be unlucky many
world says it is definitely true some
people will be unlucky but it also says
there's a lot more people than in a
single stochastic universe so to my mind
everything balances out and the progress
of Science and the updating of your
credences goes in exactly the usual way
going to combine two questions here one
is from James Allen who says say I'm
trying to examine in a basian way
whether or not I might be a boltzman
brain would I give weight to the fact
that I don't just have memories but that
they all seem coherent is a boltzman
brain that remembers all of those
episodes of mindscape posted by Shan
Caroll and in English less probable than
a boltzman brain that remembers those
podcasts consisting of gibberish and
half of them hosted by Ariel and calaban
and clao says my intuition tells me that
a balsman brain if and when it appears
won't persist as such for more than a
small fraction of time so why is it even
a useful
concept well I think both of these
questions start from the asking the
wrong question okay so the reason why
the Bol brain scenario seems a little
weird to us is because we keep wanting
to ask what is a typical Observer like
in a world dominated by boltzman brains
a typical boltzman brain
is very different than you and me okay
there was an episode of Star Trek
strange new worlds that had a boltzman
brain character in it it was very very
bad scientifically if we had done
Jennifer and I had done a little uh pie
chart of that it would be sorry
twodimensional space of of that it would
be very high on entertainment value very
low on scientific value boltzman brains
typically randomly fluctuate into
existence exist for a very short period
of time and then go away so if the
question you're asking is what does a
typical thing look like boltzman brains
look very very different than you and me
no doubt but there's another question
that you could ask which is more
relevant for questions of who do I think
I am in these universes which is not
what does a typical brain or Observer or
agent look like but rather given that I
am who I am given that I have all of my
body and all of my memories and things
like that what is the most likely
prediction for the rest of the world
okay that's a question that you
conditionalize on knowing everything you
know about yourself and that's the case
where you get a very different answer if
you believe in a boltzman brain
cosmology versus a conventional one
because it's your implications for the
rest of the world that are very very
different if the universe is dominated
by boltzman brains there will be a
essentially boltzman brain like
fluctuations that look exactly like you
that have all the memories of all the
podcasts you ever heard all of the
things that you're seeing in your room
around you right now Etc but the rest of
the world is in thermal equilibrium and
given that you are who you think you are
given you conditionalize on the
macroscopic surveyable information that
you have the boltzman brain cosmology
says that with enormous probability the
rest of the world is in thermal
equilibrium and that all of those
impressions of the world that you think
you have of memories of podcasts and so
forth are not actually attached to
podcasts you listen to those memories
just randomly fluctuated into your brain
therefore this is not a cognitively
stable situation this is not a situation
where you have any right to believe the
boltzman brain scenario even if it's
true you never have justifiable reasons
to accept that you're in a bolman brain
cosmology and be in a boltzman brain
cosmology at the same time my advice is
therefore try to construct cosmological
models that are not dominated by bolman
brains John Wyman says if I understand
Quantum field Theory correctly
everything is a field and a particle is
a vibration in the field if so this
means a planet or cat are just a lot of
vibrations in a field is that too
simplified or just wrong no that is
exactly right if you want to read more
about it read my upcoming book on Quant
and Fields and I will go in great detail
to answer this question about why
vibrations in Quantum Fields look like
particles to you and me it's kind of
always bothered me even after ID taken a
Year's worth of quantum field Theory it
kind of was rushed over in the class so
I think it's a perfectly good question
but the answer is exactly yes to what
you're
asking go mazant asks a priority
question if quantum gravity is proven
what would it look like in the classical
sense gravity is an attractive force in
the relativistic sense it is a bending
of SpaceTime given that even a planetary
level's gravity is weak what would that
translate to its subatomic levels with
all the noise that happens down there
well nobody knows sorry I know it's a
priority question but the the the
rephrasing of the question would be what
kind of quantum gravity model is going
to be the right one because there are
different proposals for what quantum
gravity might have to say at the most
microscopic level when it comes to
questions like what is spacetime what is
the structure of quantum SpaceTime
things like that is time fundamental is
space fundamental are there really
strings or causal networks or something
like that or Loops Nobody Knows the
answer to this these are all questions
that we talk about so I wish I knew I
wish I could help you but uh this is how
science works you propose models you try
to figure out which one is right in the
case of quantum gravity there are many
models that are at least semi plausible
none of them that we actually know to be
right Anonymous says should all the
universes created during Eternal chaotic
inflation be almost flat having the
observable part as being as old as ours
stretched exponentially with no Horizon
problem no magnetic monopoles Etc then
there's more to the question that I kind
of edited out but the basic question is
about what we call the cosmological
measure problem so when inflation was
first proposed the idea was you have a
any little part of the universe it would
be dominated by a temporary Dark Energy
period that would accelerate the
expansion to beat the band everything
would stretch out and get flat and then
it would reheat and you would get a
universe that looked like our hot big
bang cosmology and it was nice because
the idea was that no matter what had
happened before this period of inflation
would stretch everything out and make it
look the same the idea of ET interal
inflation is that that process happens
within some region of space but in
another region of space there's a
Quantum fluctuation that keeps inflation
going on and that region will expand and
some of it will cool but other parts
inflation will keep going on due to
Quantum fluctuations and in this picture
you don't get a unique future for the
universe there are different patches of
the universe where things can look very
very different so that raises a new
question that wasn't there in the
original inflationary model which is how
do you compare the relative importance
of one kind of area versus another and
the answer is nobody knows because the
numbers are infinite there's going to be
an infinite number of things that look
one way and infinite number of things
that look the other way people have
tried I'm not very convinced with any of
the attempts to actually answer this
question and it's a it's a very strange
situation because inflation kind of
works right I mean it makes predictions
for um perations in the early universe
and so forth that modern observational
astronomers and late Universe
cosmologists just use as a black box
right they make predictions on the basis
of it they test these predictions they
narrow down the parameter space etc etc
but this looming question about eternal
inflation draws into question whether
any of those predictions make any sense
at
all um so this is the measure problem
and and it doesn't get a lot of
attention but I think it's super duper
important I also think it's solvable
even though I don't know what the
solution is I do think that it's
completely plausible to me that there is
just some right measure that will say
most universes are almost flat no
Horizon pum Etc there's going to be a
small fraction of other universes in the
appropriate measure that look weird but
they're a small fraction so I don't know
what the answer is I'm optimistic that
it's out there I think this is a very
good problem that deserves more
attention than it
gets aian bodden says I was wondering if
you have any opinions on psychological
egoism the idea that Human Action is
always motivated by self-interest and
what about apparent
altruism well I don't know a lot of
expert level stuff about this particular
um perspective although I would very
strongly say that it is perfectly
obvious that Human Action is not always
motivated by self-interest I find it
hard to believe that anyone can actually
have experience with actual human beings
and believe that it's also perfectly
obvious that sometimes Human Action is
motivated by self-interest sometimes
it's not I see I don't see what's so
hard about accepting that that's why
it's interesting to think about human
psychology because it's not something so
cut and dried as yes it's always
motivated by self-interest you have to
be able to accept nuance and comp
lication in the world you should expect
that of human beings human beings are
not intelligently designed they grew up
under the course of evolutionary history
with all sorts of random accidents as
well as selection pressures um sometimes
a band of humans can stick together and
work in cooperation and that helps them
survive other times human beings can
betray all their friends and that helps
them survive so the selection pressures
are not at all obvious you know I think
that we should glory in and work to
understand all the nuances and
complications of human psychology rather
than trying to boil them down to a
simple
Motto Chris says what are the best
arguments you've heard for Consciousness
being fundamental and how would you
refute them you know I don't want to be
unfair here I don't know any good
Arguments for Consciousness being
fundamental um it is a point of view
that some people have and they they hold
it very strongly and there's some very
very smart people who do that therefore
I think that these people are worth
engaging with because as a good basian I
think that even though I hold a certain
point of view very very strongly um if
there's a whole bunch of smart people
who disagree with me I have to carve out
some Credence that I'm wrong but as far
as actually hearing the arguments and
being persuaded H maybe there's
something there no I have had zero
persuasion that there's any reason to
think that Consciousness is fundamental
so so can't really help you with what
the best arguments
are nich Kramer says if you were put in
charge of the grand renaming scheme for
all of physics what would your main
choices be and why for example in your
new great course which I we talked about
at the very beginning of the intro here
you described the term wave function as
a dumb boring name likewise I've heard
you express similar misgivings about
terms like dark energy and entanglement
similarly what might be a clearer less
confusing or ambiguous term for the the
many worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics yeah you know I actually
haven't thought about these a lot you
and I'll tell you why I do think that
some names are more clear than others
you know names serve two purposes one is
that they're labels right you could call
this just Alpha Beta gamma you just give
completely symbolic labels to all these
things it helps you distinguish whether
you're talking about alpha or beta but
then also names ideally would at least
suggest what it is that is being talked
about okay so wave function for
example that's just a terrible name just
because it's boring not because it's
inaccurate but because it's boring when
they invented the idea of a wave
function when schinger first wrote down
his idea of what the wave function was
it was a you know something that he used
to make predictions for hydrogen atoms
and and things like that we now think of
it and even schinger presumably came to
think of it as the fundamental
description of the state of reality
right I would prefer to call it the
quantum State or the state Vector
because it's a vector in Hilbert space
wave function just sounds like a you
know a temporary label that you put on
something before you come up with the
right one but I also think that despite
the fact that these labels don't always
convey useful
information it's not the biggest deal in
the world I'm not that worried by the
fact that these labels are not
descriptive that they're merely pointers
that they're merely labels once the
label is accepted by the world you got
to deal with it I don't think that
renaming things is a very useful use of
our time right people are have heard the
word it's better just be clear about
what the word means dark energy is kind
of fine it's not the best label um even
dark matter is is not the best label
because the important thing about dark
matter is not that it's dark it's that
it's invisible it's that it's
transparent right it neither glows which
is what makes it dark nor does it absorb
light that's what's important it's
invisible matter but that sounds even
spookier than dark matter at least in
the case of dark matter the word matter
is distinguishing it from other things
like radiation or vacuum energy Dark
Energy the word dark is just as
misleading but also the word energy is
just non-descriptive because matter also
has energy and radiation also has energy
so it's not a very helpful term in that
form but again it's accepted so people
are going to use it entanglement is
worse for two reasons one is that at the
Practical level it really does make
people think that there is some tangible
connection like a little string or a
ribbon that is connecting two different
entangled particles which could not be
further from the truth and the other
more conceptual one and this is where I
become a little idiosyncratic minority
member um I don't think the right way to
think about the world is as little
individual subsystems which are or are
not entangled that makes entanglement
seem like a mystery why are these two
different subsystems entangled with each
other how will we ever account for the
mystery of entanglement from my point of
view it's exactly the opposite you know
the world is a single state vector and
entanglement only comes about because we
insist on dividing
the Hilbert space in which Quantum
States live into subsystems and then
some of them are going to be entangled
some of them are not going to be but
it's not a mystery it's your fault
because you divided the world into
subsystems because that's easy for you
to do only if you're already thinking
classically and thinking of these
subsystems as fundamental do you begin
to think that entanglement is somehow
mysterious or weird as far as many
worlds goes people often do simply call
it unitary quantum mechanics that's what
it is uh it's the idea there's only one
wave function and it evolves uni
unitarily that is to say smoothly
according to the shinger equation but
many worlds is fine I call it that all
the time other people do language is for
people to communicate with each other
and that's
okay Dan O'Neal says have you ever
considered writing a memoir if you were
to write one how would you imagine
weaving conceptual material like your
intellectual interests into your life
story uh nope I have not ever considered
writing a memoir not anything I'm going
to do I mean I might write like when I
get to be Art's age I'm 96 maybe I'll
write like a short article telling some
funny stories about my life or something
like that but uh even myself I think
that the ideas that I think about and
talk talk about are way more interesting
than the specific anecdotes that
happened in my life along the way so
let's largely leave it at that as far as
I'm concerned Helen Ed word says I am
trying to reconcile views of the account
of physics and Free Will in reference to
past guests on the one hand and
currently popular authors and their
views on the one hand Robert spolski and
Sabina hossenfelder and hard determinism
and no free will then there's Janan
Ismael and Dan Dennett who have
amazingly reasoned views and conclude
that we do have free will even in a
deterministic universe all outline their
views so precisely yet I find they don't
fully dispute each other
yeah I I I get your frustration and
honestly I'm I I try to occasionally
answer questions about free will but I
don't like talking about it because very
very often people are just disagreeing
with um each other's words and
definitions you know in you know I I had
a podcast discussion with Robert spolski
I really like him as a person uh and as
a scientist he wrote his book determined
that just came out and I actually got
some chapters to read ahead of time so
that I could offer
commentary and his discussion of
compatibilism was just not any good uh
he clearly he was saying you shouldn't
be a compatibilist because determinism
is true and the whole point of
compatibilism is to say that Free Will
is compatible with determinism You can
disagree with compatibilism but you
can't sensibly argue that the fact of
determinism is somehow a reputation of
it because it's part of it so I would
rather and I did this when I appeared on
Sam Harris's podcast and we talked about
Free Will I said you know look let's cut
out the possibility of just having
semantic arguments over definitions by
agreeing not to use the phrase Free Will
in our
discussion I do this all the time and no
one ever goes along with me so Sam did
not go along we talked about free will
it was boring it was all about
definitions I think there's much more
interesting things to talk about than
what those definitions should be so I
would rather talk about
those P Walder says Robert zapolski once
again in an interview about his book
determined dismissed the many worlds
view of quantum mechanics out of hand
the basis for his dismissal was this
notion that many worlds allows for time
running backwards I don't recall you
ever discussing this is he right uh I
don't know if he is right uh about I
don't know what he means by time running
backwards I don't even know what that
would mean time running backwards you
know with respect to what is it running
backwards I do think that there is a
fact of our physical observable universe
which is that there is an entropy
gradient one end of time the entropy in
our observable universe is lower than
the other end of time after the fact X
postao we Define time so that early
moments are the ones where the entropy
was lower later moments are the ones
where entropy is higher if there was
another if someone chose to define a
Time coordinate which moved backward
good for them they're still describing
the same time physically so I don't even
know what that means to say time is
running backwards um all I will say is
there's an interesting again
psychological fact about people who
don't
like free will people who want to argue
against Free Will which is that they and
I've said this before they really get
beholden they fall in love with
determinism they think that the reason
why Free Will isn't thing
is because the world is deterministic
and I have to point out the world is not
deterministic certainly not the world as
it is observed by actual observers by
people because there is such a thing as
quantum mechanics sorry you can't
predict what's going to happen because
quantum mechanics says you just can't
that's the laws of physics as we
currently understand them and this is an
absolutely irrelevant to your picture of
Free Will if the laws of physics are
stochastic versus deterministic that has
zero impact on whatever you think about
free will but for some reason that is
entirely psychological people who want
to argue against free will think that
it's their duty to downplay the lack of
determinism in the laws of physics they
will say oh yes there can be Quantum
fluctuations but they're not very big
well they could be big and also even if
they were small they're still not
deterministic it's just not right why
not things that are true rather than
things that are false I don't know I
don't know why people are so in love
with determinism when it's not true have
a discussion about realities would be my
advice to these people who are not me so
they don't need to listen to my advice
Herbert burkowitz says the moon appears
larger when it is near the Horizon than
when it is overhead since we know it's
that its actual size doesn't change this
is known as the Moon Illusion there's no
scientific consensus to explain this
phenomenon although there are multiple
theories in your opinion in what makes
this nut so hard to crack well because
this is a question for psychology not
for physics or astronomy that's what
makes it so hard to crack you know at
the level of physics and objective
reality you can easily just take
photographs of the moon when it is near
the Horizon high in the sky and you can
compare their angular diameter and it is
the same as it more or less needs to be
so there's zero physics problem here at
all but remember the human brain is not
a camera okay the human brain interprets
what it sees because it wants to Keep Us
Alive you know we are subject to the
pressures of evolution and the
constraints of energy use and things
like that that's what makes all sorts of
optical illusions possible so the
question is why is this particular
optical illusion something that the
brain is so prone to I have no idea that
is absolutely a job for
psychologists I'm going to group two
questions one is from Mark Kumer who
says says you have mentioned that space
is almost C surely not fundamental while
the jury is still out regarding time
although you were the belief that time
is likely fundamental there appears to
be some tension between the statement
and special relativity where we talk
about SpaceTime as being a single entity
after all if space is emergent but time
is fundamental what is spacetime
eggental
and DOD Zod says in a theory where space
emerges from entanglement is there a
preferred reference frame I.E one that
is stationary with respect to the
entangled elements
so of course the short answer is we
don't know what is going on here once
and for all these are all conjectures
hypotheses that we're still dealing with
so the context is trying to understand
how SpaceTime maybe just space maybe
both space and time maybe just time
emerges from some underlying Quantum
State sometimes this is stated including
by me as emerging from entanglement but
as I just said entanglement isn't the
best word here the the better way of
thinking of it is
just a single Quantum State without any
pre-existing structure how can you say
that space emerges from that and and
what about time and then it seems to be
that in these attempts to do that space
and time are being treated differently
on a different footing that is contrary
to the spirit of Relativity and it's
actually worse than that because in my
favorite versions of these questions um
the number of degrees of freedom in the
observable universe is finite so we work
with a finite dimensional Hilbert space
which essentially means it is impossible
to be exactly Loren invariant where
Loren invariance is the statement of
Relativity that there is no preferred
distinction between space and time so
even though we don't know what the final
answer is I think it is absolutely
possible that in the fundamental theory
of everything there is a preferred
notion of Time Versus space and the fact
that in the world we live in space and
time seem to be on an equal footing in
that case would just be an
approximation this is very unpalatable
to a lot of physicists and I absolutely
get it uh the idea that lorensen
variance the Symmetry that Einstein put
into special relativity to make it all
work that that might not be exact that
it might just be an approximation that
it might not be fundamental this is
worrisome to a lot of people and I'm not
devoted to it by any stretch of the
imagination let me just say two things
about it one is that it would be great
to have some experimental test of these
ideas and the idea that Loren and
variance is being violated is perhaps
one of the most straightforward examples
of a possible experimental test so in
that case it that sense it would be
great the other is that our universe has
a preferred reference frame the rest
frame of the cosmic microwave
background this is typically described
as not fundamental it is a feature of
the stuff in the universe not of the
underlying laws of physics but there is
still a question where did it come from
why do we have a frame of reference in
the universe that is somehow picked out
as special this is something we don't
know the answer to on the basis of the
early universe or inflation or anything
like that we just kind of bake it in to
the fundamental description that we have
so maybe May it's not an accident that
the Universe has a preferred reference
frame if the fundamental laws of physics
do as well that's just a completely wild
speculation at this point but it's
something to keep in mind when we're
developing better theories of
fundamental
physics DC says my understanding is that
conservation laws are only true on a
Time averaged basis meaning that on a
fine enough time scale conservation can
ABS can be absolutely Savaged PV equals
nrt the ideal gas law is a weekly
emergent non-fundamental finding a
shortcut that blessedly saves us from
the horrors of statistical mechanics are
Einstein's field equations like that in
that on small enough time scales you can
violate the
equation um I don't think you're right
the conservation laws are true on a Time
averaged basis certainly in typical
physical situations like conservation of
electrical charge that is absolutely
100% obeyed all the time at the most
microscopic basis not just on a Time
average basis conservation of energy and
momentum is 100% absolutely obeyed by
the unitary schinger evolution of the
wave function of the universe Quantum
measurements violate conservation of
energy but that's a more subtle thing
and I think personally that in the wave
function of the universe everything is
still conserved of course it might be
that in a more fundamental understanding
we find that these are just time averag
quantities but uh certainly as far as
current ideas of fundamental physics are
concerned these are exact not just
approximate plant-based heisenberger
says I don't believe that humans have a
separate soul from their bodies I also
sympathize with the idea that what makes
you you is the pattern of matter that
makes up your body and brain not
necessarily the everchanging bits of
physical matter that fills that pattern
with this in mind I struggle to
understand what someone means when they
say they were born into the wrong body
what is the U that was put into the
incorrect body I understand the
confusion here but it's a purely
linguistic one you know you have to uh
think deeply about what these words mean
in these slightly more subtle contexts
so yes humans do not have a separate
soul from their bodies but that doesn't
mean you don't have a soul or you don't
have a self or you don't have a self
identity right what we're saying is that
this idea that we've had for mill pla
that human beings have souls or Essences
or selves is not fundamental is not
something that is part of your Bedrock
ontology it is emergent out of a
description that is more physicalist and
made of atoms and things like that but
exactly like tables and chairs as I keep
saying that doesn't mean it's an
illusion or it's wrong right we do have
patterns of atoms and molecules and
energy that make us who we are and we
are somebody we individuals have
preferences we have instincts we have
feelings and it can absolutely it's not
even very hard to imagine how it could
be the case that someone has desires or
instincts or feelings that they are a
certain kind of way and an actual
physical manifestation being a different
kind of way I I see no difficulty
whatsoever in a physicalist
non-essentialist view of human nature to
imagine that psychologically some people
feel happier and more natural in a
different kind of body than what they
were born into and of course
experimentally it happens all the time
in the data so if your theory does not
accommodate that I think you should kind
of try to update your theory so that it
does Ned Grady says do you read the
comments underneath AMA questions and
give them any weight to your answers in
your answers um yes and no mostly no is
the answer the way that it happens is
that on the patreon web page I look to
see all the comments at once usually
there's like pushing 200 comments and I
cut and paste them into a text file so I
can edit them remove the ones I'm not
going to read you know edit individual
questions Etc move them around sometimes
and that cutting and pasting does not
always include all the comments on
questions it usually will include like
the first comment but then click to look
load more or something like that so I
don't see all the comments and therefore
if your comment is this is a really good
question you should answer it I would
take that into consideration uh possibly
it doesn't get 100% weight but I would I
would count it and wondering whether or
not that's a question I should answer
but you should just include that as a
separate comment by all means feel free
to just leave a comment saying oh I
liked um X's comment question about this
you definitely answer that one and then
I will absolutely take that into
consideration Matt hland says if I
understand correctly there have been
shifts between the use of frequentist
and basian techniques in scientific
practice over time and basian techniques
seem to be more popular now than they
were during most of the 20th century
would it be better if the basian
Paradigm were preferred in all fields of
science or is there still a place for
frequentist
statistics you know these are debates
that go on uh by very knowledgeable
people and I'm not very familiar with
those debates so you should not take my
opinion very strongly here but for what
it's worth my opinion is that
frequentism is just a special case of
basanis basanis is a way to assign
credences to different things you're
unsure about one way to do that is to
imagine that that thing you're unsure
about is a frequency of something
happening over and over again so roughly
I think that yes spian Paradigm should
always be preferred but that doesn't
mean that frequentist ideas shouldn't be
used they they should be used in the
proper context where that is the kind of
basian reasoning that is
relevant The Great Deceiver says how can
we ever hope to understand the universe
without first understanding the thing
through by which we understand the
universe I.E the brain or
mind I don't see how it's that
complicated really it's like saying you
know how can I understand this Wikipedia
article without understanding the thing
that brought it to me namely my personal
computer in front of me I don't don't
really have a deep idea of how the
circuitry in my computer works but I can
still read the Wikipedia article
perfectly fine I think you should
distinguish between the thing you're
trying to understand and the thing by
which you do understand it I can drive a
car to get somewhere without knowing how
cars work I can do science actually
without knowing a lot about the
scientific method and certainly I can
have thoughts without knowing too much
about how the brain
works Varon Nara simitar says papers
that critique your mechanism for an e
SpaceTime tend to attack the uniqueness
of the immersion SpaceTime do you hold
uniqueness to be an important Criterion
or would you be happy to have a
mechanism that induces the emergence of
at least one such structure well I tend
to think there probably will be at most
one um SpaceTime that will emerge from a
different underlying structure but I
think that we are still trying to figure
out what the criteria are for seeing a
successful emergence I do think that in
our experience because because of how
we're embedded in the world and the
arrow of time that we have Etc we have a
very specific love for the classical
limit you know we talked earlier about
real patterns the classical limit being
applicable is a quintessential example
of a real pattern embedded in a very
different picture which is fundamentally
quantum
mechanical so I think that if you looked
for a classical limit and you looked for
uh an entropy gradient so there was an
arrow of time and you looked for
something like locality in some number
of diens ions I bet there would not be
more than one unique emerg in SpaceTime
from any underlying Quantum structure I
don't know that for sure but these are
my
guesses Callum says in 2008 he wrote an
essay entitled The Cosmic origins of
times arrow that briefly described your
project with Jennifer Chen to produce a
times symmetric cosmology have you
updated any part of that theory in the
last 15 or so years that have elapsed on
new scientific findings not very much
but I'm trying to I'm trying to to write
an article right now that you know talks
about some of the loose ends in that
model in particular I'm very interested
in whether the baby Universe scenario
that we relied upon is the only way to
make it work I think that the general
idea of unbounded entropy and a Time
symmetric large scale cosmology is a
very very interesting and good one
promising one but there could be
different ways to implement it in
realistic cosmologies so if you could do
that without baby universes I would like
to be able to do that but I haven't
quite decided whether or not that's
possible dalus kubilis says can girdles
incompleteness theorems as presented for
example in Douglas Hoff's girdle eer
Bach be applied to physics if physics is
based on theorems compatible with number
Theory they can never be complete and
consistent even if they are updated
according to new experiments I don't
think that's quite right I don't think
that you are correctly paraphrasing
girdle's incompleteness theorem the
incompleteness theorem says that a given
formal axiomatic system um can never
prove its own consistency that is one of
the theorems and another theorem says
that there will always be statements you
can make in that formal system that can
neither be proven true or false if the
system is consistent so you don't you
can't prove whether it's consistent and
there are certain true statements you
can't prove if it is consistent so
neither one of those statements has any
obstacle whatsoever to physics as far as
I can tell um physics assumes
consistency and moves on with that and
if it if you have some Theory of physics
I mean by the way I should I should back
up a theory of arithmetic or a theory of
number Theory like girdle's
incompleteness theorem directly applies
to is very different than a Theory of
physics right a theory of number Theory
says how you add things together a
Theory of physics says what quantities
you add together to make different
quantities like momenta or something
like that it's a specific model within a
general framework so I don't think that
the analogies between number Theory and
physical theories are even right from
the start but having said that in any
given physical Theory I can use the
axioms to derive theorems and things
like that and either I'm going to find
that they're inconsistent in which case
clearly I had the wrong axioms or I'm
going to find that they agree or
disagree with experiment that's how
physics goes on it's not that it can't
be consistent it's that I according to
girdle is said I can't prove that it's
consistent but that's okay in physics I
do lots of things that I can't prove
they will always be
right bits plus Adams says in her book
How the Universe Got Its Spots former
mindscape guest Jan 11 says there was no
chicken in the primordial soup but given
the initial conditions of the universe
and the determin deterministic nature of
the wave function evolution in in many
worlds isn't there a sense in which it
contained all the chickens in every
world yes there is but let's be but the
Details Matter here and I'm actually
thinking about this um in in fact in
part inspired by the conversation I had
with slavo xek on Robinson's podcast
which you can look up on the internet if
you want um the it's very plausible that
the initial conditions of the wave
function of the universe were extremely
simple
in the sense that in the sort of kog of
complexity sense of simple it doesn't
require a lot of bits to specify what
the wave function was our universe that
we see around us right now is extremely
complex in the sense that it takes lots
of bits but if information is conserved
how do you evolve from a simple initial
condition to a complex later one the
answer in many worlds is that the
overall universe is very simple but we
don't see the overall Universe we see
some little Little slice of it some
branch of it so think about um you know
a disc cut out of construction paper a
disc is very simple but I could with my
scissors cut out a very very intricate
subset of the disc and that's what our
universe is like right our wave function
our branch of the wave function of the
universe is an intricate slice cut out
of a very simple overall wave function
so would you say that that intricate
little picture that I cut out was always
there in the disc I don't know maybe
maybe not it the possibility of it was
always there and likewise for the
universe the possibility of coming up
with a branch of the wave function that
has chickens in it was always there but
you can't really read off the details of
the chicken from the actual wave
function of the universe at Early
Times Chris Gunter says do you have an
intuitive explanation for the degeneracy
pressure of P's Exclusion Principle what
can we picture as pushing particles
apart in say the pressure opposing
gravity in a neutron star the
explanation I've always heard is about
firion flipping signs when swapped and
allowing them to occupy the same state
would allow them to cancel but is there
a more intuitive picture than because
the math doesn't like it you know part
of me wants to say that the correct
explanations are always because the math
doesn't like it or more particularly
because the physical theory that we have
described using the vocabulary of math
doesn't like it everything else is just
a warm and fuzzy feeling okay the
physical theory is what actually is
telling you what's going on so you kind
of should try to learn to be happy with
that and I talk about the math behind it
a little bit in Quant and Fields my
upcoming books you can check that out
but you know depends on so since all
we're after is a feeling of
satisfaction it's going to depend on
what you qualify as satisfactory in an
explanation um the thing about Fons in
Quantum field theory is two
fermion must have zero overlap between
their Quantum States okay so it's not
just they can't be in exactly the same
Quantum State they can't be in almost
the same Quantum state so when I have
two electrons in an atom they their two
wave functions need to be exactly
orthogonal to each other that can happen
by having the spatial part of the wave
function be exactly the same but the
spins be opposite that's why you get
helium atoms and other noble gases and
things like that when you have two
different atoms what happens when you
try to push them together is that the
two electrons let's say two hydrogen
atoms try to push them together if they
were exactly overlapping those electrons
would be in the same Quantum State
that's not allowed if they're almost
overlapping then the wave functions have
a lot in common and that's still not
really allowed so you have to sort of
Imagine pulling them apart until you can
deform them in a way so there's zero
overlap between the wave functions
without putting too much energy into the
system so there's a push and a pull
right the atoms want to be close
together
because uh you know the total energy is
lower if there's no difference between
the things but the P Exclusion Principle
won't allow that to happen so you have
to look for the lowest energy state that
is allowed by the requirement that the
two wave functions have no overlap if
that has no uh explanatory value to you
then sorry I don't know quite what to
say DMI says would there be a difference
between a bet that quote when an initial
pure Quantum State under goes
gravitational collapse to form a black
hole the final State at the end of the
black hole evaporation will always be a
pure Quantum State and unquote and a bet
that quote information can escape from a
black hole unquote well there's a
slight difference in how those are
stated but I think morally they're the
same if what you're asking is when
physicists say can information escape
from black holes is what they mean that
a pure state will evolve to another pure
State even if it goes through black
holes as an intermediate State then yes
that is exactly what they
mean Tim Converse says if we encountered
an alien civilization that had advanced
math and physics how different do you
think their math and physics could be
from hours for example human
mathematicians think the remont
hypothesis is interesting and Central is
there any reason to think that
interestingness is also objective and
would be shared you know honestly I
think it's a very good question I don't
really know the answer I could easily
imagine it either way let's put it that
way I could imagine that aliens think in
such a very different way that we
haven't thought of ourselves because we
think like we think that their idea of
what mathematics is is just entirely
different you know Tim modlin who was a
recent mindscape guest has this project
where he reinvents all of topology based
on lines rather than sets and he's
interested in relativity in the arrow of
time and things like that there's a
reason for doing that um Emily reel who
is another mindscape guest from a while
ago has a way of of a different way it's
not just her but there's a group she's a
part of that has an entirely different
axiomatization of all of math that
doesn't use set theory but instead uses
some constructions from C atory Theory
whether or not these end up with very
different final sets of theorems you
know they have to be compatible with
each other but they could seem very very
different so I could imagine that aliens
would have even more different ideas
about mathematics but I can also imagine
that even though the aliens are very
different they're still in our same
physical Universe they're still driven
to care about the same things triangles
and circles are still very important
maybe they have more or less similar
ideas about math I think it's a very
interesting empirical question that I
don't know really know how to
judge Eric dovigi says who is your Mount
Rushmore of NBA
basketball you know this a tough one
again because I'm not a big ranker of
things I'm not a big uh Lister of things
but if you forc me to do it this wasn't
a priority question but I like to mix up
the questions so here's a little bit of
a of a breather um you know I think that
the two best basketball players of all
time were probably Michael Jordan and
LeBron James I think that's the sensible
way to go there and in fact I would
pretty easily put Michael Jordan first
and this is even though it's pretty easy
it's not necessarily
quantitative um that's the impression I
have from as someone who has watched
both Michael Jordan and LeBron James
play basketball a lot at his Peak when
Michael Jordan was playing if you were
on the other side because I was never
rooting for him I was rooting for the
Sixers and they were playing against him
um and even when he was playing somebody
else I was generally rooting for the
underdog which the other team always was
when Michael Jordan was playing uh you
really always had the impression that he
was going to win that if he you know he
didn't always win of course but it just
seemed like a weird bizarre fluke when
his team didn't win because he was just
so overwhelming and so Central and so uh
accomplished with LeBron you know he's
won a lot he scored a lot Etc but you
don't have that same impression I
literally watched the Sixers play the
Lakers the other day and the six
destroyed the Lakers the Lakers are who
LeBron is playing for now and admittedly
he's an old man he's very very uh
advanced in his age LeBron he's played
more minutes in the NBA than any other
human being ever has but you know look
to be honest I barely noticed him you
know he scored some baskets but he he
looked very human very ordinary and
Michael Jordan never looked ordinary to
me still given all of his
accomplishments I think you got to put
LeBron on there and and then I think and
this it pains me as a Philadelphia 76ers
fan um I think you got to put Bill
Russell on that list also not the most
talented um basketball player in some
ways but he just won he won basketball
games all the time and at the end of the
day that's what matters he was by far
the most effective winner in the history
of NBA basketball and he also won the
Olympics and in high school and in
college and everything he's the guy you
wanted on your team when you wanted to
win a game I think that should count for
a lot and then I think you have to put
Wilt Chamberlain on the list also
because if you look in the record books
the things Wilt did no one else ever did
and in terms of statistics in terms of
scoring and rebounding and block shots
and all these things uh he led the
league in total number of assists one
year um he was the most amazing physical
specim specimen and athlete that NBA
basketball has ever seen so if there's
four people on Mount Rushmore then those
are the four I would probably put on of
course my personal favorite basketball
player was always Julia iring because Dr
Jay was the guy who got me interested in
basketball from the start and I think
that modern ways of judging basketball
players very much underrate Julius
Irving um there's a reason why the
Sixers went to the NBA finals in half of
the years when Dr J was on their team
and have only been back once in many
decades since then he was a winner also
and he did it in ways that were not
always obvious he scored but he didn't
score more than anybody else he also had
a lot of steals a lot of assists a lot
of blocked shots and you know you can
play games in the
basketball statistics databases like
basketball reference and you can look
for things like what basketball players
have in the history of the NBA or
ABA averaged you know more than this
number number of blocks steals assists
points and it's not hard to find
criteria such that Dr J is the only
person who shows up on those lists he
was also endlessly entertaining and a
wonderful person to have on your team so
I have a special place for him even
though he's not top four of all
time Christian Doo says in last month's
AMA you said you find it incoherent when
people who say Free Will is an illusion
are still trying to make choices as well
as trying to convince others about
making choices as well can you help me
point out this contradiction in my mind
they are not saying the illusion of Free
Will doesn't exist or that is not
Central to our everyday Behavior
moreover they say that lacking free will
the only thing that can actually change
your mind is an outside influence like
trying someone trying to convince you to
do or to not do
something uh I mean I don't even know
what to say um for one thing the only
thing that can change my mind is an
outside influence just seems wrong to me
as someone who has changed my mind mind
before but let's put that aside my point
is uh if if you think that Free Will is
an illusion then you should also think
that moral responsibility or
praiseworthiness or blameworthiness is
an illusion if the only thing you
remember
compatibilists are perfectly happy to
believe in the laws of physics and that
human beings obey the laws of physics
what that means is there's a perfectly
consistent and comprehensive way of
talking about what happens in the world
that never mentions human beings Free
Will choices anything like that it's
just Adam's obeying the laws of physics
but the compatible say there is another
way of also talking about the world
where there are humans and they do make
choices and in that way of talking we
can assign moral goodness and Badness to
the choices that they make what I don't
see is how you can say there are no
choices choices are Just an Illusion but
I'm still going to say that some Cho
choices are good and some choices are
bad I think that's pretty obviously a
contradiction to
me Robert Holmes says do you have a list
of criteria for distinguishing pseudo
science from real science I'm especially
interested in critiques of astrology it
has no established mechanism but neither
did Gravity at first its predictions
aren't 100% true but no model in science
ever is so what sets astrology or other
pseud pseudo Sciences apart honestly
here I am uh again in a minority
perspective here I Almost Never Go
Around calling things pseudo science I
certainly don't go around worrying about
some distinguishing criteria for saying
this is science and this is pseudo
science I'm perfectly happy to call it
all science I just say that some of it
is bad science and some of it is good
science the problem with astrology is
not that it's pseudo science that it
doesn't fit some madeup criteria for
what's really science the problem is
it's just crappy in making predictions
it is completely disconnected from other
things we know about the universe and
there's no reason to believe it's true
you can call it science if you want I'm
just not going to call it worth my
time David Maxwell says movies and games
let us digitally create sights and
sounds in increasingly realistic way
experiencing things we never could in
reality my childhood dreams of digital
sense remains elusive but if if it
happens in our lifetime what new old
factory experiences might you dive into
so I have no idea what new olfactory
experiences might be worth diving into
all I will say is that if you haven't
already you should go back and listen to
the podcast I did with Ann Sophie barich
who is a philosopher of smell as
philosopher neuroscientist she actually
has a lab where she disc discusses these
things and I'll I'll warn you ahead of
time smell is very very tricky part of
how we appreciate smell is extremely
contextualized one thing one chemical
can smell very pleasant in one context
and very unpleasant in another context
so I I don't know what will happen when
we can digitally generate smells because
we're also going to have to digitally
generate an entire context to put them
in before we say whether they are
Pleasant or
unpleasant Larry Herzberg says you often
mention David Lewis's approach to modal
logic when discussing how philosophy
deals with the topic of possibility but
I've never heard you mention Sal kpk's
popular alternative kryp Key's approach
does not posit the existence of other
equally Real Worlds containing
counterpart objects that are merely qu
qualitatively similar to those in the
actual World rather he views possible
World talk as just a convenient way to
analyze the truth or falsity of
counterfactual statements about actual
objects based on our modal intuitions
about the necessity or contingency of
their properties I was just wondering
whether you're familiar with kpk's
approach and if so what you think of it
I am only very very tiny amount uh
familiar with kpk's approach and you
know from the little that I have heard
I'm actually more sympathetic to it than
I am to Lewis's approach personally I
think that the idea of possible worlds
is absolutely crucial for how we talk
and reason about the one actual world
but I'm not a modal realist I don't
think that the other possible worlds are
actual in any real sense if that is also
what kryy is saying then I am completely
on board with what he says the only
reason I always refer to David Lewis is
the philosophers I hear talking about
these ideas mostly talk about Lewis's
version of it so someone like Barry
lower in particular thinks of what he is
doing as building on David Lewis's
approach to modality in possible worlds
um Lewis did get into details about uh
physics and time and things like that so
that might be why the people who I talk
to more often reference Lewis than kryy
but that's I'm not trying to
implicitly uh judge one as superior to
the
other Wade dun says is there a
recognized group of accredited
scientists who are proponents of a young
Earth and also anti-evolution that
aren't openly
religious no not that I not that I know
of certainly I mean there well so there
is no recognized group of accredited
scientists I don't know what it means to
be an accredited scientist uh I do not
know of any group of serious scientists
who are proponents of young Earth
cosmologies whether or not they are
religious Nick Gul says my question has
to do with the role of coar graining and
what it does to our perception of
complexity is it possible that the
eventual decrease in complexity in our
universe is only apparent due to the
fact that the structural complexity of
the cream mixing into coffee may
continue to increase but only it scales
smaller than the coarse grain cut off
anything's possible but uh we're
thinking about so this is in reference
to the paper I've been working on with
Scott Aronson an update of our old paper
on uh the the origin and evolution of
complexity en closed systems with cream
mixing into coffee as our paradigmatic
example the setup that we care about is
the phrase closed systems in that title
refers not just to systems that are
isolated but systems that obey
deterministic underlying laws of physics
right like we think classical mechanics
is or uh unitary quantum mechanics is so
in that case complexity must be
something that arises from coar graining
because if you have deterministic
reversible underlying laws then the
total amount of information contained in
the state is constant over time it
doesn't go either up or down so the
complexity can't go either up or down it
is only once you combine reversible
underlying laws plus some macroscopic
course graining that what we call the
apparent complexity can go up and then
go down and that's exactly what happens
so the eventual decrease of complexity
is yes it is apparent in some sense but
it is also real both things are true
because in the real world we actually do
course grain the universe we do not see
all the microscopic things going
on Jim Spangler says reading a blog post
about Sam bankman freed I came across
that he's the guy who got indicted or
maybe convicted by now I don't know for
the FTX cryptocurrency
scandals reading a blog post about him I
came across a tweet he made back before
his life fell apart and challenging the
idea that Shakespeare was the greatest
writer in the English language he says
quote the basian priors are pretty
damning about half the people born since
1600 have been born in the past 100
years but it gets much worse than that
when Shakespeare wrote almost all
Europeans were busy farming and very few
people attended University few people
were even literate probably as low as 10
million people by contrast there are now
upwards of a billion literate people in
the western sphere
what are the odds that the greatest
writer would have been born in 1564 the
basian priors aren't very favorable now
notwithstanding that the fact that
literature is subjective this strikes me
as extremely bad reasoning but I can't
put my finger on why what do you think
well I think that the fact that
literature is subjective is relevant
here more relevant I mean clearly
overwhelmingly relevant is the fact that
the idea of having a greatest writer in
the English language is not very well
defined right what do you mean the
greatest writer um Shakespeare certainly
isn't the bestselling writer that's
that's if it's not the Bible then it's
Agatha Christie or someone like that
right but Shakespeare is arguably the
most influential writer he coined an
enormous number of words he um set the
stage as it were pun not intended for
the way that we think about poetic
language and drama in general and
characterization and things like that um
he pioneered forms of historical plays
and tragedies and comedies Etc you know
anytime you see a comedy of errors
whether it's the Marx Brothers or The
Three Stooges or whoever Shakespeare
literally wrote The Comedy of Errors
right there are reasons why the kinds of
situations that arise in aello and
Hamlet and Romeo and Juliet are used
over and over again in modern dramas but
guess what if that's your definition of
the greatest writer the one who is the
most influential in a good sense then
you shouldn't put a uniform prior on all
the writers who have ever lived it's
much easier to be influential when you
were born earlier okay so I just think
it it's kind of silly this kind of
argument that is given in the quote
because it starts from an ill-defined
idea the greatest writer of the English
language it then smuggles in an implic
IIT assumption namely that your prior
should be uniform over every person who
was born and then reaches a conclusion
so the logic there is just based on a
whole bunch of sketchy assumptions this
is a big problem overall for people who
consider themselves to be rational it's
not okay just to have some assumptions
and draw conclusions from them your
conclusions are no stronger than your
assumptions and so you have to be very
careful that your assumptions actually
accurately track with the world and
there is a very human flaw that people
have which is they like their
assumptions to be simple they like them
to be easy and clear and cut and dried
as we talked about with teen Wen back a
while ago right Clarity and simplicity
are just really really seductive to
human beings so the idea that we just
take all human beings give them an equal
chance of being the greatest writer in
the English language and then act
shocked that the the greatest writer was
in the
1600s it's natural it's compelling but
it's actually not very rational at
all Jeffrey seagull says the discussion
of the reality of mathematics in the
last AMA was interesting and made me
wonder how Justified some of our choices
for mathematical Solutions are in
engineering complex numbers can be used
to describe amplitude and phase for
example but starting early we're told
that the real life solution for x^2 = 4
is plus two and we should simply ignore
the minus two alternative as not
realistic is there a deeper
philosophical rationale for this Choice
do you have a basy and prior regarding
How likely it is that we might someday
discover that the minus two alternative
could be interpreted in terms of the
physical
world well I think that the Deep
underlying pH philosophical principle is
that you were taught
badly there's no reason whatsoever to
say that if x^2 equal 4 is all you know
that you should ignore the minus 2
solution and stick with the plus two
solution what is probably going on is
that you don't only know that x^2 equal
4 there is some context in which you're
trying to understand something right
like if someone says I have a number of
pebbles in my hand and I will tell you
that the number of pembles squared is
four then you can reasonably conclude
that they have two pebbles in their hand
not minus two because the space of
possibilities is only whole numbers
natural numbers I guess 0o 1 two 3 Etc
right you can't have minus two pebbles
in your hand so there is a physical
context in which some solutions are
physically reasonable and some are not
but there is no AR priori pH
philosophical rationale that you should
always choose positive roots to
algebraic equations to polinomial
equations that's just not a thing that
you should ever rely
on Mike Meyer says whether it's
discussing current topics in physics or
the history of physics you seem to have
a talent for recalling the names of
significant individuals and their
accomplishments are you especially good
with names or does this mainly come from
repeated exposure to these topics I'm
certainly not especially good with names
you know I'm as embarrassed as anyone uh
or or more than worse than average when
it comes to remembering the names of
people who I've met personally um and
I'm hilariously bad at remembering the
names of uh actors in movies and things
like that you know I'm that's just not
something my brain is very good at I
think probably what if to the extent
that your very nice compliment has any
relationship to reality the point is
that as someone who spends time writing
about these topics for a broad audience
or talking about them for a broad
audience it is often the case that I'm
interested in looking up some of the
history for how things happened right um
looking up so exactly what happened when
Isaac Newton uh came up with the ideas
behind the pipia Mathematica or the real
origins of remian geometry and things
like that so I do a little historical
digging like I actually read remon's
paper on remani and geometry which
essentially nobody has ever read in the
modern world where we use ranian
geometry if they did they would realize
that most of what we think of as ranian
geometry was developed by Italian
geometers after reman but that's a
different story but you know it's
reading these stories that makes the
names stand out it's not because I have
any special facility for names but by
knowing a little bit about the actual
history and the stories behind them that
brings the people to life and that helps
you remember their names I don't know if
that's good advice overall but I think
that's where I get these names
from dragons sided D says have you seen
any candidates on the Democratic ticket
that you think would be preferable to B
Biden in the primary and if so why
either way I'd appreciate your thoughts
on the US Presidential Democratic
primary uh happy to give you my thoughts
my thoughts are that Biden is going to
be the nominee unless some disaster
happens um disaster to Joe Biden not to
not to the world uh he's going to be the
nominee deal with that you know I I
completely understand uh and urge to
challenge candidates in primaries you
know we have a weird system in the
United States where because of this
thing called the presidency and because
of our particular first P the post
voting systems everything about the
system encourages there to be two and
only two political parties and that
dramatically Narrows down the space of
possible candidates who can get elected
especially for Nationwide office um it's
a very very narrow Spectrum indeed in a
parliamentary system where one where you
had ranked Choice voting or something
like that you might imagine a wider
spectrum of possibilities and by the way
the wider spectrum means not only more
people with weird extreme views but also
more people in the center right the fact
that you have to have two and only two
parties means that to get uh nominated
by the parties you have to be a little
bit away from the center rather than
right in the middle of it so anyway I am
entirely on board with complaints about
the system however given the system
system that we have something that you
have to do as a grown-up member of a
Democratic Society is choose between the
actual candidates it does not help you
or the world or the country to say well
here are the candidates on the ballot I
don't like any of them therefore I'm not
going to vote that makes the world a
worse place I'm sorry I don't again you
don't have to like the system you don't
have to approve of it but until we
change the system you have to deal with
it and right now
with overwhelming probability absent
some Health crisis or something else
like that as of December 20123 the
Democratic nominee is going to be Joe
Biden and the Republican nominee is
going to be Donald Trump unless he
literally gets thrown in jail or
something like that um so work to change
the system by all means but the the idea
of running someone against Biden the
primary is just sort of it's not serious
you know it's it's wish fulfillment
fantasies and I I think that uh politics
is a place to be serious especially once
the elections once the nominees are
known Paul toic says I'm still thinking
about the episode with Katie Elliott you
dismissed the relationship between
patterns laws of nature counterfactuals
you sorry you discuss that's important
the relationships between patterns laws
of nature counterfactuals and causality
previously you've said that causality
requires more than just that events are
related by laws of nature emergent
macroscopic asymmetries must be added
but where in these structures and
explanations do counterfactuals come in
are laws counterfactuals and physical
properties part of a theory building
package deal as former mindscape guest
Barry lower would have it um yes that is
correct laws counterfactuals and
physical properties are part of a theory
building package deal the point is once
again none of us is Theus demon okay
none of us has exact knowledge of the
world if we did if we had exact
knowledge of the world and the laws of
physics
sure we would know everything that
happens in the past present and future
but we would never need to refer to
ideas like causality or even laws of
physics we would just know everything we
just know what actually happens okay
where all of these other things come in
is because we have imperfect information
because we don't know everything so if
you want to say the I you know my
typical I don't know why this is my
favorite example my favorite example of
causality is I was late because there
was traffic there was a traffic jam on
the road it's weird this must be from my
Los Angeles um past because I walk to
work now that I'm in Baltimore it's very
convenient and traffic jams do not get
in my way but what does it mean to say I
was late because there was a traffic jam
as opposed to saying I was late because
of the wave function of the universe and
the schinger equation that latter thing
would be true but it's completely
uninformative the former thing I was
late because was a traffic jam
implicitly refers to counterfactuals
what do you mean when you say I was late
because there was a traffic jam you mean
had there not been a traffic jam I would
not have been late otherwise your
statement isn't really saying anything
you can't say I was late because 2 plus
2 equals 4 right that's not something
where had it been different there's an
obvious Consequence the had it been
different is playing a crucial role
there again I don't think that these
ideas are fully settled yet I think that
this is why this kind of Science and
philosophy is still very very
interesting but um there's there's some
very crucial role being played in how we
ordinary human beings talk about the
World by counterfactuals and the reason
why this is very interesting to a
physicist is what is a small deviation
from the real world and what is a big
deviation right this is something the
philosophers I don't think have gotten
completely clear about and maybe some
Physics has something to offer there
Brendan says some theologians seem to
get bothered by the need to explain
God's origin and they compare that to a
naturalist view that the Universe does
not necessarily need an explanation I.E
it is eternal they seem to think that's
a double standard to me it appears
reasonable to stop at the universe as a
brute fact since it is within the
natural world whereas something outside
the natural world like God would need a
bit of explaining are there other
aspects to this concept I might be
overlooking well I guess I think about
it differently than you are implicitly
thinking about it here for one thing I
don't think there's any connection with
whether or not the universe needs an
explanation and whether or not it's
Eternal I can very easily imagine a
self-contained physically consistent
story of the universe for which time has
a beginning I just don't see any problem
with that whatsoever that does not imply
some extra kind of explanation I do
encourage you to read the paper I wrote
about this why is there something rather
than nothing try to be very clear about
what my ideas are here I I talk about it
also a little bit in the big picture but
the paper why is there something rather
than nothing is a much more clear uh
complete uh statement of how I think
about this so I don't think that whether
or not the universe had a beginning
matters the question is what kinds of
things demand explanations I don't think
that many things demand explanations I
think that explanations are convenient
when they exist I think that just like
causality just like we were just talking
about they are features of higher level
emergent phenomena the fundamental
nature of reality in my mind simply is
what it is you will always reach a
Bedrock when you're talking about oh
this is true because of that that's true
because of this other thing you will
reach a bottom and you'll say this is
how the universe is it's not some other
way and that's true whether or not God
is part of your fundamental ontology so
I don't count the explanatory needs as
either Pro theism or pro- naturalism to
be honest I do think it's fair you're
kind of alluding to the idea that a
theistic ontology is more complicated it
has both the natural world and God in it
whereas naturalism just has the natural
world that I think is fair I think
that's perfectly fair to say the
naturalism is simpler and then the
question is is it too simple uh I would
I would reject naturalism if it were
simple but it failed to account for
things that we actually observed in the
world I don't think that's true so I'm a
naturalist but that's how I think that
the logic would
work Aaron anathema says I hear that
neutrinos are notoriously difficult to
detect because of their low mass but
photons have no mass and I have two
surprisingly effective Photon detectors
my eyeballs how does that work easy I
like this question I like the easy
questions the answer is the fact that
neutrinos are notoriously difficult to
detect has absolutely nothing to do with
their low mass absolutely zero you could
have low mass particles that are very
easy to detect like photons as you point
out or ones that are very difficult to
detect like neutrinos or for that matter
gravitons or axons or other things like
that the reason is because the mass of a
particle is a completely independent
parameter from the coupling strength of
a particle the coupling strength and
again plug I'm going to talk about this
a lot in my upcoming book The there are
interactions between different kinds of
particles that we can Define in particle
physics so the electromagnetic
interaction is what happens at a
particle physics level when a charged
particle like an electron or positron or
proton for that matter either absorbs or
um emits a photon the force carrying
particle of electromagnetism and in
particle physics we associate that with
a strength a certain coupling constant
and the same thing is true for neutrinos
or for axons or gravitons or whatever
it's just that the coupling constants
for neutrinos and gravitons are much
much smaller than the coupling constants
for photons so the photon coupling
constant is already pretty small it's
the fine structure constant 1 over 137
but for neutrinos it's way way tinier
nothing to do with the mass that the the
coupling constant is an independent
parameter Douglas dicki says priority
question I've always assumed assume that
complex numbers are used in quantum
mechanics because ironically the
mathematics involved is more
straightforward in principle I assume
that it would be possible to develop a
valid treatment of quantum mechanics
without the square Ro TK of minus1 I in
sight is that correct yes it's
absolutely correct indeed you can go
further there is absolutely nothing that
is done with complex numbers that could
not be done without complex numbers
they're just
convenient um
complex numbers have the property that
you can write them as a plus I B where A
and B are real numbers and I is the
square < TK of minus one and you combine
that together to make Z that's the
complex number but then there's a
special property that there is a a a a
map from complex numbers to themselves Z
goes to the complex conjugate of Z in
the real number way of talking that's I
goes to minus I or so B picks up a minus
sign in a plus IB so you can just by
hand by Brute Force replace all of your
z's with a plus ib's and then rather
than having I just invent a new rule
that you have an ordered pair a comma B
with the property that there's a map
that sends a comma B to a comma minus B
and you can multiply them together in
certain ways and secretly you're just
doing complex numbers but you're never
mentioning complex numbers this would be
ugly it would not be much fun but if you
really didn't like theun of minus one
you could absolutely do
it Ari Mai says when the universe
experiences heat death am I right that
fundamental particles still exist just
infinitely separated and if so would
particle ement I think I think we meant
entanglement there as a typo
entanglement still be possible after the
universe's heat death well yes and no
um I I think that this is a case where
your intuition is getting the best of
you because the fact that the particles
you're talking about are excitations in
Quantum Fields actually becomes
important um at the heat depth of the
universe in a universe like we think
we're in with a non-zero vacuum energy
the universe asymptotically approaches
its vacuum State I guess that would be
true even if the vacuum energy were zero
but the the status of the vacuum state
is a little bit different in the
universe with a cosmological constant
the vacuum state has a non-zero
temperature it's called the bunch Davis
vacuum after the two physicists who
first solved the equations and so if you
had a thermometer you would actually
detect a nonzero temperature of that
means that you would detect a photon
occasionally right rarely but
occasionally the point is you don't have
a photon detector you don't have a
thermometer because it's in the vacuum
there's no U there's no thermometers
there's no devices so there's just a
quantum mechanical State and as I said
you ASM toote to a quantum mechanical
state which is the vacuum state that
means that there aren't any fundamental
particles lying around there is just a
quantum mechanical vacuum State um you
can ask but what about particles that
have left my observation my observable
universe left the
Horizon there it's a little bit tricky
whether or not they still become
particles you know when the universe
reaches heat death everything smears out
right everything becomes closer to
thermal equilibrium and the notion of a
particle becomes less and less obviously
relevant let's put it that way so I
would just advise people if you if
you're not really into all the math and
getting it exactly right and you just
want a handwavy way of thinking about
this think of the universe as emptying
out and there being no more particles
left
around Ron Graber says in your recent
solo podcast on artificial intelligence
and AGI you presented an argument that
llm SL gpts do not model the world can
you say more about what you've learned
about how conscious beings like us do
model the world put another way if llms
aren't on the path to AGI in part
because they don't model the world what
does our understanding of human general
intelligence suggest that path will look
like well I guess the best thing I can
do is point you to the podcast I did
with Gary Marcus maybe also we talked
about this with Melanie Mitchell or
steuart Russell I don't remember exactly
the details but the idea is that there
can you can imagine symbolic
representations of the world so in other
words you have the world here I'm
looking around the room I'm sitting in
right now I say oh look there's
something called a table there's
something called a coffee cup there's
something called a computer a microphone
Etc and all of these have different
relationships to each other coffee cups
are often found sitting on tables tables
are solid and have certain sizes all of
these facts right and a model is just
sort of this set of facts and the
relationships between them whereas
something that an llm does are not
models of the world like that but rather
sentences now it's interesting because
it's con completely conceivable that if
you have a model of the world and then
you said out loud every sentence you
could think about that model coffee cups
are often found on tables things like
that the information would be equivalent
right maybe enough sentences essentially
determine a model of the world that is a
something you could conjecture how would
you test that conjecture and what I
tried to argue in the podcast was one
way of testing whether current
generations of llms in fact implicitly
spontaneously generate a model of the
world is not just to say oh the llm
sometimes make mistakes because that's
obviously true they absolutely make
mistakes you have to ask what kinds of
mistakes they make do they make the
kinds of mistakes that they naturally
would if all they were doing was
calculating probabilities of sentences
and words or tokens or whatever you want
to call them versus having a symbolic
representation of the world and with the
examples that I gave I tried to argue
that at least in that informal set of
evidence um yes the llm seem to be
making exactly the kinds of mistakes
that they would make if they were just
trying to say what words would most
naturally follow previous words rather
than referring back to some symbolic
representation of the world I don't know
a lot about how actual human general
intelligence works so that's a very good
question I'm you know I'm not an expert
in these things I'm looking forward to
how we learn more about them my main
goal in the podcast was to emphasize
that llms aren
built to be general intelligence and
therefore although it's remarkable how
intelligent they can sound we should
still be suspicious whether or not
they're actually generally intelligent
and when you press them in exactly the
areas that you imagine they would fail
they often fail so I think that it makes
perfect sense that story that's not to
say that we can't eventually make
general intelligence Gary Marcus says we
got to work with symbolic gen um
approach es to AI along with
connectionist language model kinds of
models maybe that is the way forward I
honestly don't
know Nita says on episode 51 with
Anthony air you said that you don't put
High Credence in inflationary cosmology
only 50% why is that and what's the
creative alternative that would allow
for distant regions in the CNB to have
the same temperature at 3 degrees Kelvin
well I think 50% is an enormously big
Credence honestly the point in my mind
is the place in Cosmic history where
inflation purportedly happens is way way
way beyond anything of which we have
direct experience right the energy
scales the time
scales um just the part of the universe
that we're talking about is entirely
speculative you're invoking new physical
Fields New initial conditions new
phenomena etc etc etc and it kind of
works right you kind of get the answers
that you want to get it works remarkably
well to the extent that I'm happy to put
a 50% Credence on it but the other 50%
is not some other creative alternative
the other 50% in my mind is something we
haven't thought of yet we're talking
about the origin of the universe here
why in the world would we think that we
have a 99% Credence of having the actual
correct answer already in hand I think
that any good basian would always put
some Credence on something we haven't
thought of yet when it comes to the
first 10 to the minus 30th of a second
in the history of the Universe I think
that creedon should be pretty
big Michael lesnak says I'm going to
answer two more questions and they're
both a little more frivolous because the
holidays are coming so Michael lesnak
says being that Thanksgiving is my
favorite holiday I have to ask do you
enjoy the traditional Thanksgiving meal
and if so what is your favorite part
short answer is no I do not enjoy the
traditional Thanksgiving meal I've just
never been a fan of turkey you know I
like a good turkey sandwich with some
you know lettuce and mayo and things
like that but the big roasted turkey
I've just never been a fan of it's too
easy to make it badly I understand some
people can make it well um but it's too
easy to make it badly it's usually kind
of dry and flavorless to be honest I do
like um stuffing and I like gravy not a
big mashed potatoes guy so overall I can
imagine a halfway decent Thanksgiving
meal but I certainly don't look forward
to it in any particular way you know
it's telling that we don't make roasted
turkey on many other days of the year in
fact when we lived in Los Angeles
Jennifer and I had a tradition of going
to Las Vegas over Thanksgiving and
having peeking duck on Thanksgiving Day
at Jasmine in the bagio so we were
eating poultry at least but a much much
tastier poultry than everyone else was
having for their Thanksgiving Turkey um
now that we're on East Coast uh this
year we just gave up we did we we've
been too exhausted with moving in and
doing my job and things like that so we
I didn't leave the house during the
entirety of Thanksgiving week the nice
thing that Hopkins does is you get the
whole week off so what I did was uh on
the weekend before I went shopping and I
bought a whole huge amount of food and I
spent the whole week cooking different
things so we had paa and we had pasta
carbonara and you know a whole bunch of
different things that I really enjoyed
cooking so that was much more fun to me
than the traditional Thanksgiving meal
and then the final question is from
Norman ramian who says given the end of
the year holidays are upon us I have a
cocktail question for you what is your
preferred ratio of Jin or vodka to
Vermouth for a classic Jenner vodka
martini shaken or stirred favorite
garnish you know I've written and talked
about this quite a bit in fact I had a
holiday message podcast a few years ago
that talked about cocktails but I tried
to be a little bit expand about that so
it was less about the actual mechanics
of cocktails um I have different
opinions that are of different levels of
firmness and the overall opinion is
whatever you like right I mean I'm
absolutely not a prescriptivist when it
comes to Cocktails so when I give you my
opinions Please interpret them as my
feelings not as objective truths with
that in mind um there's no such thing as
a vodka martini that's just a uh an
Abomination the whole point point of a
Martini in particular or of cocktails in
uh General is to enjoy a combination and
an interplay and an interaction between
different kinds of flavors okay so there
are two problems with how many people
make martinis one is if one of those
ingredients is
vodka vodka doesn't have much taste at
all if you sip vodka or you take little
shots of vodka small amounts pure vodka
and you do a taste test with different
kinds of vodka then you absolutely can
taste the difference between them
there's different mouth feel different
little tiny spices that leak into it but
they're very very subtle and you really
have to be pure about it vodka is not
supposed to be strongly flavored so if
you put into a martini you're putting
vermouth in there which is somewhat
strongly flavored and you're not going
to get any interplay between vodka and
vermouth especially if you don't put
much vermouth in there then you don't
have a martini you have a vodka
transferral system and it's basically
good for getting drunk so go nuts have
your vodka put it in orange juice get
drunk wherever you want my preference is
to have a subtle interesting Martini
which is a cocktail which relies on an
interplay of flavors so first one of
those should be Jin because Jin has
flavors indeed for those of you who
don't know roughly speaking Jin is
flavored vodka you can buy Jin making
kits I have one it's it's tremendous fun
so you get a bunch of Botanicals right
that by flavoring I don't mean like put
you know food coloring in there or
or high fructose corn syrup or something
you get Botanicals you get herbs
primarily Juniper if it's traditional
gin but you get different kinds of
Botanicals and you can uh seep them
Infuse them into vodka to make gin and
if you have your gin making kit the good
news is you can make your favorite kind
of gin and it's actually very good it
can be very tasty the bad news is
professional distilleries will after
they do that infusing remove all the
color because generally those Botanicals
are going to uh impart a slight color to
your gin so like pure gin is actually
slightly yellow and it's not actually
very attractive looking but it still
tastes really good and I'm not even much
of a traditionalist about Jin you can
get very very good my most my favorite
traditional gin is St George's uh
terroir gin which I think is very good
mostly Juniper Etc but there are also
Japanese Gins the Japanese are more
playful about it you know they have tea
flavors and Yuzu in there and everything
and it can be very very good and then a
cocktail again is based on the interplay
and there therefore you're going to want
some vermouth in there there's this
weird Macho thing where people try to
brag about how little vermouth they put
in their cocktail in their Martini which
again if then you're just drinking
Jenner vodka which is fine but just do
that so I would like at least um let's
say 20% of my so that's a 4:1 ratio of
JY to Vermouth and I'm I'd be perfectly
happy with a 3:1 ratio as well um
shaking or stirred little Lally makes no
difference it absolutely does not change
the um taste there are aesthetic things
I guess the one way there's one way that
it changes The Taste which is that if
you shake and stir for the same amount
of time shaking is probably more
effective at cooling down the martini
and if one thing must be true about a
martini it's that it must be cold the
low temperature is crucial for martini I
kind of got in trouble at a friend's
house a little while ago where they knew
knew that I liked martinis they were
very excited about serving martinis and
they gave me a martini at room
temperature and I was not able to hide
my disappointment which was not very
polite as a guest I have to say sorry I
I I just couldn't help myself felt bad
about that um cold cold cold cold is
what you what Martini to be and so
shaking works for that but you can also
it can Cloud up the martini a little bit
again it doesn't change the taste at all
but if you want that absolutely crystal
Clarity in your Martini stirring is
better PS don't take advice on anything
from James Bond okay people forget that
when Ian Fleming first wrote James Bond
he was not supposed to be the role model
of sophistication he was kind of not
sophisticated that's why he wears wrist
watches that are sort of divers watches
like omegas and Rolexes that's not what
you're supposed to wear with your tuxedo
and these shaking martinis are not right
either okay so I actually stir my
martinis most often but I again don't
object if you want to shake them as far
as garnishes are concerned this is
crucially important and where I am
absolutely a pluralist I will have
olives I will have onions I will have I
think if it's an onion then it's a
gimlet or something like that right it's
it's or a different name but it's to me
it's still a martini um I will do a
twist and when I do have the olives
sometimes they're with a pimento
sometimes they're with garlic sometimes
even a jalapeno it all depends on my
mood um I think you should do them all I
think you should enjoy whatever you like
and in fact that is holiday advice of
more General applicability don't hurt
other people be nice to them talk to
them and listen to them and within those
constraints enjoy yourself have a good
time be who you are uh oh I forgot to
say at the beginning we take the the
holidays off so there is no January AMA
and there is no um Christmas Day
mindscape podcast so if you only listen
to the amas you'll hear me again in uh
the beginning of February otherwise I'll
talk to you next week have a good
holiday holiday time period however you
might construe that in terms of
Celebration
[Music]
bye-bye
w